okay
good morning
just don't want us to get too far behind
okay we'll now open the public hearing
on Senate Bill 19 relative to bingo
dates and for the record I am a licensed
Bingo consultant
so the chair recognizes daily frenet
welcome to a house ways it means thank
you
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee my name is Daley frenette
and I am the Senate majority caucus
director I'm here this morning to
introduce Senate Bill 19 on behalf of
senator avard
Senate Bill 19 FN amends RSA 287-e colon
6 by increasing the number of permitted
Bingo dates per licensee from 10 to 16
per calendar month overall this bill
increases the total number of possible
Bingo dates from 120 dates uh game dates
per licensee per year to 192 game dates
per licensee per year
this this bill simply provides the
option for Charities to hold more bingo
game dates it does not require bingo
halls to Grant more game dates to
certain Charities to the detriment of
others Senate bill 19fn was recommended
ought to pass by the majority of the
Senate Ways and Means Committee and the
bill is ultimately passed on a Voice
vote by the Senate thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to speak
this morning I will defer any questions
to those behind me who will be able to
better answer your questions thank you
okay uh Senator the chair recognizes rep
thank you madam chair for the record I'm
Cindy Rosenwald I represent Senate
District 13 in Nashua I'm a co-sponsor
of this legislation and I'm here to
offer a friendly amendment to your
committee for consideration which
doesn't
um
change anything about the number of
bingo dates but simply allows an
employee of a bona fide charitable
organization to claim fifty dollars of
expenses rather than the current
sorry did we do we have that friendly
Amendment yes
okay so it looks like it was uh Senator
Susie's name is on it yes is that okay
yeah and so it's Amendment over in
Commerce okay now so
the moving finger of fate fell on me
we're lucky to have you uh so it looks
like it's an amendment 1403 s does
everyone see that
so it just basically changes it from 25
per day
to 50.
questions from the committee are you
representative Susan all me
thank you
and I've been I was wondering before
this how would you they get the
charities
that could staff three to four days a
week
um but
on if they increased the number of of
days but
maybe this solves that I think this
would help solve that I mean it may not
be the same staff member
who staffed
an additional number of dates but if
people are to the extent that people are
not covering their expenses
to staff the Bingo dates
this would help
them be able to do that and it doesn't
require
fifty dollars it just raises the ceiling
I see a so representative Jordan ulery
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for taking the question
um two questions the first question is
on your Amendment uh can you tell me
what
generated the
impetus or what was the impetus for this
probably someone behind me can do a
better job
their answer used it myself
and the second second question follow-up
I'm the follow-up question on that is on
the on the primary Bill uh since the
year of the number two sponsor on this
on the primary Bill if you increase the
number of days
is the information you had and was it
discussed in the Senate whether or not
increasing the number of days would
dilute the pool of players by having
for lack of a better phraseology too
many games available
the lack of players
that there was no testimony in the
Senate that that would be an issue
thank you Matt oh thank you senator
representative Susan Allman did you have
a follow-up question
thank you yes I've been trying to find
my copy of the amendment which I'd put
with 192. so on what kinds of expenses
um
I don't believe there's a statutory
explanation of it I know what kind of
expenses I might try to claim if I were
working for one of these entities it
might be gas needed to go from where I
live to where the bingo hall is it might
be food if I needed to pick up dinner on
the way might be um
to pay for a babysitter if I had to
and just as I mentioned I have been
involved in this field a little bit and
it is this is a very helpful Bill and as
amended it's also very helpful because
it is hard to get these are mostly
volunteers for a charity and it's hard
to get them to come up and they do have
legitimate expenses of Transportation a
meal while they're sitting there those
kinds of things are normally appropriate
and 25 doesn't go as long or as far as
it used to so other questions from the
yes thank you for taking my question you
said this is a friendly Amendment and
the prime sponsor is is aware and
supports he is not because he's in
Florida but I consider it a friendly
amendment I have not heard that there's
any opposition to it so we offer it as a
friendly Amendment he is on vacation and
other questions from the committee
thank you senator
okay the chair recognizes Mike
McLaughlin from Community representing
Community Bingo
welcome
thank you madam chair members of
community my name is Mike McLaughlin
malarian lobbyists and conquerative
represent Community Bingo and are here
to testify in support of Senate bill 19.
um Senate Bill 19 will give the
Charities who play Bingo and sell Lucky
7 tickets an opportunity to get extra
dates uh if they become available again
it's not a mandatory uh requirement that
you do 16 dates uh more uh I'm more
interested in the uh the amended version
which allows
volunteers to receive the compensation
was more reflective what costs are today
I mean four dollar gallon gas and too
low and I mean I've got grandchildren
they have to pay 50 a night for a
babysitter all these changes were looked
into by the lottery we had discussions
with the lottery and they offered no a
contrary uh opinion against raising the
limit to fifty dollars again it's a
thing that it would help get people to
work and it's interesting to note in the
Bingo Lucky 7 world as opposed to the
the casino world where the Charities
have the operation which is completely
handled by Third parties so they have
don't have to recruit people to come
into work they really have a better
opportunity because they've got
professional people running their games
whereas the Bingo Lucky 7 world is
dependent on the charity recruiting
I see some hands up are you open to
taking questions did you have anything
else to say before we could go off okay
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um we talked about expenses that could
be reimbursed potentially
um let's say someone just lived down the
road and they walked there
um could they claim I think I should I I
should be paid fifty dollars for
compensation is that a legitimate
expense or does it have to be well when
I think you talk about an expense
sometimes there is gasoline or
babysitting but there's also if you walk
down there and you help set up the
chairs clean the hall uh make sure the
bathrooms are clean all those types of
assistance uh things that you could say
to the charity and you and the amendment
says you submit your expenses in writing
it would be the charity we would say to
you and those those are ridiculous we're
not going to pay for that but we are
going to pay you to take down 200 shares
or to wash the windows or something that
helps the game assist in the operation
of the game so the charity may say no uh
the um
there's no specifics in the statute
today that says you know washing the
windows is no good but you know setting
up the chairs is so it's the I think a
charity uh it would be kind of looking
at the expense and maybe not tonight but
you walked you know down the street
thank you I saw something yes
representative Platt yes thank you for
taking my question this is more to do
with the increase in game days
will that make it harder for Charities
to find any games uh days because it's
crowded out for the longer days but
those who do get in
the um the availability of of commercial
Halls could be a concern
but again the um I don't have
information in front of me there was
testimony in several different points
from Charities that we might get fruit
frozen out but that's a consideration uh
if there are enough Charities who want
to participate
um they could have a commercial
opportunity right now we have several
commercial Halls one of mansions that I
know that I represent uh there's one in
Hudson there's one in Nashua which is
here today uh so the
the net result of the bill
could have an impact on Charities but
it's um
right today it's written because there
are dates hanging certain Halls that
aren't used so it is it would be unfair
to say that yeah then there would be no
effect but I don't see today in our hall
for instance we had two Charities leave
other yes representatively
thank you my questions related so how
does how does it work when a new charity
approaches you and said and says we'd
like to have a date do they like get in
line behind the ones that are already
um
familiar with you and work with you is
it your decision how does that work well
commercial Hall is basically is renting
the floor space to the charity five
dollars per person up like maximum of
ten uh they get foot traffic so the idea
of who's going to get it is a charity
that can perform the best because
commercial Hall does not share in the
proceeds of the game they don't share in
the Lucky Seven they don't share the
Bingo all they share in it is the foot
traffic so if the um uh XYZ charity
comes in and says we can guarantee two
or three hundred people a night uh we're
gonna prioritize them over the charity
Associates we're just getting started we
have no idea what we're doing how about
a date so it's a commercial decision of
who can provide the best result for the
charity and for the whole because the
Halls are commercial real estate they're
taxed their electricity
etc etc so they must make the decision
that's commercially reasonable uh with
relation to the Charities who apply uh
to Bessemer Lodge uh we've had waiting
lists and we do it chronologically if
there's five people on the waitlist uh
number one gets in next but a charity
that's just starting out having really
no experience is gonna have a hard time
convincing a hall that they can fill it
up at night
follow-up
so it seems like a reasonable concern
that if we
um increase from 10 to 16 days that
whoever runs the Halls would prioritize
giving more days to the most successful
Charities if it's a Biz purely a
business decision well I think you're
going to run to that decision no matter
what you do because we've got for
instance the casino style gambling has a
tremendous amount of success and a
tremendous amount of Charities looking
to get in everybody can't get in it's
going to be the same with a commercial
bingo hall that if you're going to have
an opportunity you're going to look for
the best best client so the only thing
that solves those type of questions is
more commercial Halls because it's going
to be supply and demand it's a the
commercial Hall is a business Enterprise
they have only one thing to do with the
charity that's provide the floor space
they collect their five to ten dollars
per foot uh foot traffic and hopefully
can I have another one
you follow thank you so um obviously
I've never played I need to get out more
um and you never would have if it's a
question of having foot traffic you
would never have two charities
um come in at the same time because that
would be more maybe two smaller ones
that just doesn't work it's interesting
to say that but today a bingo date is
granted to one charity okay some Halls
are able to run two um dates per day at
maybe at 10 o'clock and four o'clock in
the afternoon or two o'clock and eight
o'clock at night so Elijah Hall can run
two nights and interesting enough years
ago there was a bill passed I know the
guy who had it done it was me to join
Charities together in electronic Bingo
the licenses were there but really
nobody could find the software to make
it happen so putting two Charities
together in one Bingo good is not
allowed okay thank you so much thank you
all right I saw some hands over here yes
how many of the bingo halls are outside
of the big cities at this point
I can only uh test Friday three I know
of
that they're in Nashua Hudson Manchester
I don't know of any out in the
Hinterlands only because of the uh
population issues
okay so follow up we're really thank you
we're really only talking about the big
places there were was in this one and I
think in another one I've been reading
the Senate notes and the the hearing
notes and the
um there was some worry
that everybody agreed that that a lot of
the people who go to the bingo hall are
not just there to socialize with each
other at this point with their friends
but are chasing the biggest jackpot and
the biggest jackpot occurs when the
smaller jackpots
build up as I understand One credit card
carry forward or whatever it's called
not that's from a different language but
uh
um
and that so that if you had 16 days your
charity would have more chance of
building up a really big jackpot and get
more people from the other charities in
the same city
that were um we're only at 10 or less
there was one person apparently they
only had one day but on
this this seems to have been moral worry
in the other bill
that we were looking at
but that we will be looking at but
on do you have
any comment on I think you were
actually
listed
as saying something about yeah that can
be a problem
I don't understand exactly what you want
which is a progressive Jackpot Bingo
game and that game can create jackpots
to 10 20 30 40 000 but what we're
talking about bingo today bingo today is
not the
really funded a hundreds of supported by
members of the chart it's a social uh
event but it's on the internet each
commercial level system our commercial
has a Facebook page the Facebook page
covers the people who are the Charities
were playing publicizes their jackpots
so when you talk about the Bingo play
today that player is looking in the
social uh media looking for the best
place to play so as the jackpots grow
yes the uh the uh foot traffic increases
and more Bingo dates will in if you have
a progressive jackpot will add you know
exponentially as your jackpot grows more
people show up so yeah a charity who is
uh running 16 dates and running a
carryover coverall and selling Lucky
Sevens is going to have a successful
charity
fall
I I think this is from the notes on the
other bill but someone pointed out that
if the jackpot is won then that Hall
for a while after that is going to have
less jackpots than anybody else and so
it in the end it might work out
well in our home we have more than one
charity so if a large jackpot is hit
with Charity X charity y may have a
similar or a little bit of lesser of a
jackpot on Tuesday night than charity a
had on Wednesday night so it's it's a um
it's a constant uh flow of uh Lucky
Seven jackpots carryover coverall
jackpots there's um you know a large
jackpot attracts people to come into
play
I see other hands representative
Schomburg thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question uh who
audits the expenditures are submitted by
The Bona Fide members of a charitable
organization
well
um if a child organization hires a bingo
consultant somebody to help them out
they usually help them do the paperwork
so the paperwork is then audited put
together and sent to the lottery and the
lottery that has the opportunity to come
down and inspect the books and do the
audits so it's a kind of a it's either a
charitable member or does the books or
they hire a bingo consultant to help
them with the professional preparation
then to the lottery then the lottery can
say okay let's go down and visit Hall X
or charity y we look at the books if the
books are clean they off they go and if
the books are bad the chair the the
lottery steps in and
um either gets corrective action or
who pays for the itemized expenditures
is it the charitable organization or is
it the hall
the hall has nothing to do with the
Charities only the five dollars to seven
to ten dollars they collect per person
the Charities are just like renting a
grocery store the the landlord has a
billing the grocery store has these
so it is the
charity that pays the individual correct
oops other hands on that side of the
room representative fellows
yes I live in the hinderlands
so I don't I'm not familiar with these
setups it says from what I can gather by
looking at the bill in the fiscal note
it's the chi the charity
pays a 25 fee to the state for each game
no the charity does not pay to the state
collects taxes on the proceeds of Bingo
and lucky 760 25 or the now that would
be fifty dollars is paid by the charity
so
you talked about the licensing yeah I'm
looking at the the methodology on the
fiscal note and it says that there are
52 charitable organizations licensed to
offer Bingo no I was I was responding to
so yeah they would pay an additional a
bingo date they would pay if they had
additional dates they would put
additional licenses fees
um my question is
are there any other fees involved with
this because I I understand the
operation that you run and Charities
kind of like you know give you a cut to
cover using the Halls that you have but
what about other Charities can charities
use the you know
Foreign Legion Hall or some other just
general location and they and they get
the the helper person consultant to
cover that well I'm just trying to
understand if we're talking about just
something that's in a very select area
or could be happening all over the state
a small charity or any charity can get
licensed and they can hold their game in
a location that's approved by the
lottery so if you have a hall in your
Hinterland and x and the charity wants
to run a bingo game they can apply for
their license uh set up their operation
in in that Hall then they don't have to
collect the the uh pay the fee as a
basically a rent for the hall they can
run their own game what's happened in
the last 20 years is the uh somebody saw
an opportunity to put together multiple
charities in a single location and
therefore increasing the foot traffic
and the pro proceeds so if you are
sitting in the Hinterlands you can run
your own game
thank you
okay on this side of the room any
questions
on this side are there more questions
representative Susan Ami well just a
clarification on we have Penny Bingo we
have one penny Bingo uh in the senior
centers
I presume they aren't paying the state
anything
well if there's a penny a card
Bingo collects I think uh seven percent
tax on all type of bingo games so if
you've got a Penny Bingo uh and the
price is 10 cents they're gonna get
0.007 or what I mean I don't know if
they're uh I can't really justify to
that
yeah this individual is representing his
commercial bingo hall so he can't just
comment on all but I I believe they
don't pay yeah but we probably don't pay
thank you very much okay we will now
recognize Rick Newman who represents
thank you madam chair
my name is Rick Newman and I am here
today representing Spartans Drummond
bugle uh core out of uh Nashua we
support uh Senate Bill 19. uh I just
want to focus on the the primary bill
for for a moment
so not every commercial bingo hall is
the same right there are some that have
plenty of Charities and they can operate
every day seven days a week
and there's no problem
but in some cases as we've seen over the
years there used to be about 18
commercial bingo halls I just tried to
look up and try to answer the question
asked about where they're located I
couldn't find it on the website but I
believe we're down to about six now in
the state
um and not all of them
well many of them want to run seven days
a week but they can't necessarily do it
because they don't have
enough Charities even you only need four
but Bingo is a very difficult game to
run because Bingo requires all it to be
run by charity volunteers so you have to
get people who are willing to come in
and spend several hours every day to set
up and and run the bingo game and that's
why we're looking to change this from 10
days maximum to 16 so that if there is a
bingo hall that can't fill seven days a
week because they don't have four
Charities that want to do it but they
might have two that are willing to do
the 16 or 15 days then that Hall can be
open seven days a week and those
Charities can benefit that's the that is
really what this bill is about it may
very well be that
uh some Halls will never take advantage
of it that makes perfect sense if
they've got five or six uh Charities to
be able to be open seven days a week but
for those who can't for those who have
difficulty
um this bill will help them and that
that's the reason that we ask that it be
introduced
uh are you open to questions yes
representative Susan almie
thank you so
those
on six Halls are all in three cities
correct but well I know that people are
having trouble I know there's one in
Dover there's one in Nashua there's one
in Manchester
there's one in Hudson
off top my head those are the places I'm
trying others well there is a hall here
in Concord but not sure if their quality
if they classified as commercial because
they only run their own bingo
the
what is it
Temple yes back touch Temple they run a
bingo game at their own Hall but I don't
believe that that's a commercial Hall
um
as I said there used to be commercial
Halls really throughout the state
Portsmouth Somersworth had them
Newington I can remember
have them these Halls have disappeared
all the questions from the committee
saying none thank you for your testimony
okay the chair recognizes Paul LaFlamme
I think it's drum and bugle Corps as
well yes I'm actually the executive
director of the Spartans uh Drummond
bugle Corps Senator avard submitted this
bill at my request and so you can blame
me as to why you just spent an hour or
half hour talking about bingo uh so yes
my name is Paula flam I'm the executive
director of the Spartans we have been in
business since 1955 when my grandfather
founded the organization we are based
down in Nashua but we take great pride
over the course of our summer tour every
summer 8 000 miles we don't just
represent Nashua we represent the
entirety of the State of New Hampshire
as we perform and compete throughout the
country
since 1955 Bingo has been a huge part of
what we do it has allowed us to sustain
ourselves and continue on um to get to
today
there's only three of us left in an
activity that used to have three drum
cores in every single community
Bingo allows us to have a steady
consistent Revenue stream to keep our
lights on all year
and
um
over the course of the last five six
seven years with the expansion of the
casinos and The Kino and the HHR
machines and all and sports betting
our revenues have been slightly going
down let's face it there's only so many
gambling dollars available to the
consumer so by expanding our base of
operations here and able to do three
weeks instead of or three days instead
of two days a week would really help us
minimize those losses
I'm going to try not to repeat anything
that has already been said but there are
just a couple of things that I I just
would like to touch on that were
questions the question about jackpots uh
representative olami yes jackpots will
if somebody were to take on three days
of bingo per week yes jackpots would go
up but guess what it's the exact same
odds so they're going to come down just
as quickly you're actually dollar cost
averaging over time probably a little
bit better
um how to staff
that was a big question here how are we
going to staff three nights of bingo
well some Charities might not be able to
and that's okay the word shall does not
appear anywhere in Senate bill 19.
Charities may have three nights of bingo
if they think they can staff it but if
they can't they don't have to that's
aren't us that's that's the decision of
the Charities to make that decision
um
representative leapley you asked uh the
the process of of getting new Charities
into place it's a good question
20 years ago it was probably even a
better question because there probably
was waiting lists of Charities trying to
get into these bingo halls however with
the especially with the expansion of the
casino gaming or charitable gaming
a lot of Charities have left bingo and
they realized how easy it is to sign up
with a casino
fill out the paperwork wait a couple of
weeks and get a check Bingo's a lot of
work I can testify under oath to that so
a lot of Charities are like we're gonna
do that instead which leaves a lot of
openings it was already said during the
house uh hearing or the Senate hearing
rather I talked about one of my
competitors the Hudson Hall had two
nights open
that they they contacted me three
different times and said hey how about
coming over to Hudson we're so much
better than Nashville come on come on
come on come on
I chose not to do that
but guess what's happened
two Charities have left another Hall in
New Hampshire to go over to Hudson
leaving that Hall that they left in in
trouble so the idea that there was all
these Charities lined up it's just it's
just a fallacy it's not true it's just
not
um
I think that was all the questions but I
would love to have questions from the
committee
questions from the committee yes
representative lippley thank you I
remember reading
um
in the
hearing notes that this is a popular
social activity for seniors
um can you talk about
um that and if it's something that folks
enjoy and it's only available once in a
while and and the availability is going
to go down can you comment on that
availability go down if this bill passes
now if the Halls aren't doing as well
and oh I see what you're saying yes or
can't be open as many nights a week sure
um it's absolutely a social activity
um and I think I can probably I can
speak directly for the national Hall but
I'm going to make a leap of faith and
say it's probably true for all of them
we have a lot of regulars like they come
in on their regular scheduled night I
play Bingo every Monday and Thursday or
whatever the case might be we open up
the doors at three o'clock there's
people standing there waiting to get in
Bingo doesn't start until seven o'clock
so they go to the kitchen they get a
snack they sit down they talk they get
to be friendly with all the volunteers
and they know each other by name and
they tell stories it becomes a whole
social event for the entirety of the
afternoon
and a lot of these people not all of
them there is a there is a what I call
uh the soccer mom
um demographic that's starting to come
to Bingo but there's still the very
traditional older person who's sitting
in their home all by themselves and this
is their one one opportunity to come out
and and visit
so I think we do feel a very important
representative horse thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
so just a little while ago you said a
couple Charities went to Hudson where
well I don't want to talk out of turn uh
I think there's probably people behind
me that belong to that Hall I don't want
to say anything that's
incorrect or it's not it's not the
national Hall I can tell you that very
I don't have any other pink cards on
Senate bill 19. is there anyone else
here to speak on that
okay seeing none we will close the
foreign
we will now open up this uh hearing on
Senate Bill 139 relative to the price of
Lucky Seven tickets
and for the record I'm involved with
Lucky Seven
and I will now recognize
daily frenette who was representing
good morning again members of the
committee again my name is Daley
frenette I'm the Senate majority caucus
director and I'm here to introduce
Senate Bill 139 on behalf of senator
avard
Senate Bill 139 allows private clubs
service clubs and fraternal
organizations such as Legions and the
VFW calls to stay competitive with Lucky
7 tickets by raising the maximum wager
amount to ten dollars
the bill was recommended ought to pass
with amendment by the Senate Ways and
Means Committee by a vote of four to
zero the committee amendment clarifies
that a higher that the higher Wagers are
only allowed on electronic dispensing
devices because there was a concern
about the potential for dishonest
practices with higher Wagers on paper
tickets
the bill is ultimately voted out to pass
with amendment by a Voice vote in the
Senate thank you again for allowing me
to speak this morning I will defer any
questions to those behind me
thank you thank you very much
okay next up we have Rick Newman
thank you madam chair
uh Rick Newman and I am representing
Grover gaming Grover gaming is a
supplier manufacturer of uh
Lucky 7 dispensing devices and I want to
start off by saying yes this bill passed
the Senate with allowing a ten dollar
ticket
we are here to ask you to modify that to
make it a two dollar ticket not a ten
dollar ticket currently the maximum
ticket price is one dollar
after you know really looking at this if
you think about some of the changes
you've made to Lucky Sevens in the last
several years one of the most important
being that you increase the deal size to
000 tickets
having a 10 ticket would allow a deal
that would could be would would be could
be as high as 140 000
um we think there may be some unintended
consequences of something like that
having rethought this and but we do
think that the increase to two dollars
would be very beneficial let me just uh
explain here that uh I know you see a
lot of gambling and then a lot of you
may be new to it so lucky seven tickets
are primarily sold
in service clubs veterans Halls those
kinds of things vfw's Legions
um
and uh and and the like I mean they also
they're also sold at bingo games Okay
um they are not generally sold at the
casinos the games of chance facilities
that I also happen to represent there
are to my knowledge there are two out of
the 15 casinos that still sell some
Lucky Seven tickets
uh but so so this isn't really affecting
the casinos in any way it really is
giving the opportunity for a legion of
VFW the Eagles Club
um it's primarily affecting them
allowing them to sell a ticket uh go
from one dollar to two dollars I think
it will be beneficial to them and we
would ask you to support the bill
and do we have such an amendment or is
that something you'd like us I'm
suggesting it to the committee I would
be happy to I mean it really is a simple
change of Crossing out 10 and putting in
two okay
um but
are you open to questions sure
just just to make sure that I've got
you or uh people you've worked with were
the prime movers for the ten dollars
then you rethought it and now it's two
dollars and there's no is there are
there any we may hear from them I
suppose any uh any that are pushing for
ten dollars not to my knowledge
representative
uh we'll find out I guess I guess we'll
find out yeah but right now as far as
you know
um you were pushing for 10 and now
you're pushing for two and
that's what we've got that's what you
want that's correct yeah
all right other hands over here super uh
representative Susan on me
thank you but I think
the clerk was ahead of me but sorry
about that uh representative Platt
all right uh thank you for taking my
question what's the concern about the 10
bucks what would what what what what's
keeping you from going there well one of
the things we if you look at it one of
the changes that you folks made
um I think it was last year
was to allow Lucky Seven tickets to be
sold at games of chance facilities at
the so-called casinos right
so as I said there are 15 of them right
now only two do take part in it but if
you were to combine the law you passed
last year with a law allowing a ten
dollar ticket
you may find that may encourage somebody
somebody could open up theoretically a
games of chance facility uh and put in
100 Lucky Seven machines there's no
regulations on that subject matter right
now and I think I don't think that's
anything anybody intended for that to
happen and that's not what we're looking
to have happen
so that would be one of the things that
caused us concern to say we should put
the brakes on this and think about it
but we certainly would like to help the
okay back to representative Army Susan
Army yeah thank you
on
oh dear now I've
so what I thought you were saying before
was that um
how many tickets did we say could be in
a deal now fourteen thousand fourteen
thousand so that would be uh if somebody
got that ten dollar ticket early on
they'd have to pay out a hundred and
forty thousand dollars
well no their potential would be 140 000
in the pot let's assume 10 is set aside
you get 90 percent of that so you'd have
somewhere neighborhood of 100 to 26 000
in prizes yeah there but you could be
offering very large prices
in that kind of a game
yeah I think we learned about this
earlier but that most of the people here
weren't here at that point
so the the problem with Lucky Seven
and I'm not sure how I can't remember
how it works for the machines that on if
you have a box everybody knows that
somebody won that top ticket
and if the top top ticket was won after
you've been through a third of the Box
the rest of the box is useless
so that happened also with the machines
well
no well I can't say no but it's
certainly less likely because you we
also allow the combining of up to three
deals at a time so with electronic games
they're pulling from different deals in
other words I guess the answer to your
question is a player is always going to
have an opportunity to win an electronic
game it is possible you could have a
dead box with a paper ticket which is
one of the reasons that in the Senate we
added the language that the ticket above
a dollar
would be in the electronic game only
so could I have it if nobody
said it helps the veterans halls and the
Brotherhood lodges the reason
um the reason Lucky Seven came into
existence was to help the bingo halls
so actually the history of Lucky Seven
tickets goes back before
there was a time and I happened to have
been in the house when it happened uh
when I was on a DNA back in the I think
it was the 80s and Lucky Seven tickets a
bill was put in to allow the sale at
bingo halls prior to that they could not
sell them at bingo halls they were only
sold in American Legions of vfw's eagles
clubs that sort of thing and uh and I
don't mean to be leaving any groups out
until just the ones that come to the top
of my head but then that law was changed
and I want to say it was the 80s to
allow Lucky Sevens at bingo halls
um thank you
representative ORS
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I guess I'm still
confused to ask what is the concern with
a 10 ticket is it is it concern that the
payout could be more than the receipts
more
on a regular basis no the concern would
be that we we don't want to set up a
situation where all of a sudden you have
50 locations open up that become nothing
but Lucky Seven powers
well that's that's not the intent yeah
what's the problem with that well we
I can understand some people might not
think it's a problem but we would think
that's a problem why I I just don't
understand I don't think it's the intent
of the statute I think the Lucky Seven
sales we have limited uh gambling in New
Hampshire we've limited charity gaming
meaning the casinos we limit who can
sell Lucky Seven tickets
um and I just think that
I think before if that's the road you
want to go down the legislature should
be taking a serious look at what how to
do that and I don't think we're there
yet I don't think we've done that yet
follow-up
follow-up does it impact other games is
that the concern well it could it
certainly could I mean if you were to
open up a parlor across the street from
the uh if you go to the strip mall in
Epping there's an American Legion there
that sells Lucky Sevens they probably
have a four or five machines there but
if you opened up a place across the
street and put in a hundred uh Lucky
Seven machines and you had you know
promotions and whatnot that could very
well impact that that Legion
got it no question
right oh yes representative Doucet
Jen thank you for taking my question we
heard the uh Lottery director testified
this morning in reference to HHR
machines we're talking about an
electronic gaming device
um I guess my question is to the people
who operate the Lucky Seven machines go
through the same vetting background
check criminal check financials check as
do the the people who
operate HHR and that answer is no and
that is exactly representative one of
the concerns that you you don't do
anything near that uh level of scrutiny
all right other questions on this side
well it started out as what people would
call a pull tab right you rip the card
off and you reveal whether it could be
cherries or number sevens or some kind
of symbol and you win a prize that's we
call that Lucky Seven across the country
it's called different things but it's
you know I think most commonly known as
a pull tab ticket so if you think about
that ticket uh the legislature has
passed laws to allow in addition to the
paper pull tab we have electronic
versions of that where you can sit and
press a button and reveal those boxes
and those prizes
they are a contained deal it is
different than a regular electronic game
in other words we talk about a deal
there are there are a maximum number of
tickets in each deal which of course
then limits the number of prizes and how
many prizes or how much prizes can be
awarded
a Canadian
thank you madam chair
um can you explain why why is it that
only um the dispensers can pay can or or
what the theory behind the dispenser is
only doing two dollars but paper tickets
I can
um
the Lucky Seven tickets are sold by
humans in the in when they're in when
they're in the paper form right
uh somebody mentioned I think it was
representative Allen he mentioned the
what if the if the prize gets hit on the
first ticket out of the box that box
becomes sort of worthless right
well reverse that suppose there's a
hundred tickets left in the box and
there's a top prize of X whatever that
is a thousand dollars and it hasn't been
hit yet
so if I'm working the bar
and I know that
I could buy that box out and get that
ticket or I can call my friend to come
down and do it and so when we started
talking about the bigger number
and of course as we were talking in the
senate about 10 but I think it's valid
even at the two
we said you know we should limit
that type of potential activity
by saying put that higher price ticket
in a game that essentially cannot be
tampered with
thank you
representative Susan Ami thank you uh
Lucky Seven machines you haven't said
that yet but they're
a lot more stodgy
than the slot machines that are the
historic racing machines and don't tell
me they aren't slot machines all of the
people that are talking about it outside
of this place say they are but
and they're a little bit slower than
historic racing machines than slot
machines are but the Lucky Seven
machines as I understand it and as I've
in the past seen these things unless
they've evolved on do not have the bells
whistles and and uh colors and noises
that the slot machines have
why would anybody open up a ten dollar
slot machine um sorry um
Lucky Seven machine place
well I don't know I can't answer that
directly why they would except if
somebody sees an opportunity to make
money I assume they will try to take it
we've seen people come in and we have
those sweepstakes machines out there in
the Marketplace for a while the
legislature took action to get rid of
those so I think
thank you very much thank you madam
chair
okay chair recognizes Mike McLaughlin
again from Arrow
Arrow
thank you again Madam chair members of
the committee my name is Mike McLaughlin
and Lauren Law Office in Conklin
represent Arrow International of
Cleveland Ohio arrow is a major supplier
of Lucky Seven uh tickets and equipment
to New Hampshire
um we're in support of the bill as
written and I think it's important to
note the 14
000 uh maximum amount of tickets in a
deal has no relevance to whether the
ticket's tend AutoZone we can design
ticket runs at 500 200 600 3 000 it's
irrelevant to the discussion on whether
we should have a ten dollar ticket
nobody's going to have 140 000 to or
whatever the net cost is to buy a roll
of fourteen thousand Lucky Seven tickets
as with the ten dollar ticket but the
ten dollar ticket and the bill as it was
uh put forth in the Senate and supported
in the Senate will allow the Social
Clubs who are now competing against
other gambling entities and what was
seen here in the last year or so last
five years is we have two repeating
gambling paradigms we have the
charitable casinos and we have the Bingo
Lucky 7 world
and the Social Clubs Lucky Sevens the
bingo at the casino world has uh table
games and HHR machines and the build you
guys passed a couple of weeks ago puts
the HHR bed up to 25 dollars
so what we're looking at is a
competitive world where one half of the
world is looking for a ten dollar ticket
while the other half of the world has
got a 25 ticket they also have I think
they were looking to raise that to 50 in
the Senate so the 10 ticket
in the VFW of the American Legion would
not be a hundred and forty thousand
dollars worth of tickets in the machine
it would be enough in the in the machine
to give an interesting and a competitive
jackpot and would allow or help the
people who use the Lucky 7 machines to
maintain their base so when the Alpine
Club in Manchester or the Ukrainian club
or the VFW selling one dollar tickets
now uh would get the opportunity to sell
a ticket that is more in line but still
uh 80 percent less than what's being
sold in the casino so a little bit of a
competitive balance by having a ten
dollar ticket no one has to have it uh
to think that somebody's going to run
out and start a Lucky Seven parlor I
can't imagine it but to look at the base
they have today and tell them you're
going to be able to get a ticket that's
more competitive and still less than
half of the tickets available in other
venues it's a fairness issue I'd rather
see the bill would be raised to a 25
ticket but again the maximum limit of
tickets is irrelevant to the discussion
because it's never going to happen
um
Lucky Sevens of the lifeblood of the
Bingo Lucky 7 world as we talked before
the Bingo pays about 87 percent of its
take to the player Lucky Sevens have a
guaranteed return when you buy a box of
Lucky Sevens or a deal of Lucky Sevens
the charity knows what they're going to
make because a certain percentage goes
out in prizes and the rest goes in their
pocket uh it's the player knows that
there's a certain percentage they're
going to win their absolute wins you can
play a slot machine or a not too too
familiar with HHR machines but there's
no um a player can sit down and play for
two days on a slot machine and maybe
never win a nickel
but a Lucky Seven deal has guaranteed
return and that's why the Charities use
them they know what they're going to
make so we at Arrow would design deals
that are attractive to the player and
affordable to the charity so we strongly
support the 10 ticket again it's a
other questions representative leapley
um so if
if uh entity wanted to buy wanted to
have seven dollar tickets could they do
that or is this like 10 1 and 50 cents
well there's Now 50 Cent tickets in the
dollar takes for paper and if they want
to create or look to this bill and say
the uh ticket shown a lot of C ten
dollars they could have a 5.608 I don't
think whatever the manufacturer would be
willing to create because in order to
create these tickets you have the
technology that has to be put together
the design of the game the games are
designed to be attractive they're not as
attractive as um uh you know bells and
whistles but they are not black and
white uh pieces of paper they're they're
exciting a little bit for the player to
look at but you could have any tickets
you any size ticket you deem up to a
so um I get that uh
that there's no requirement
to have a ten dollar ticket if this
passes but
um
but it's permissive so
so it's allowed if this goes through and
why wouldn't a casino
uh see this is another way to attract
customers you know everything's on the
margin so it might be that there's some
people out there that would like this
kind of machine it's a little bit
different why wouldn't they uh
um go to something that becomes more
I'm I don't know but I see no reason why
I wouldn't if it's the uh the whole
gambling world is based on how much I
can make and the algorithms that created
the HHR machines have a certain
guaranteed return we know the operator
is going to get 12 percent of the uh the
net machine drop and if these if these
gonna have Lucky Seven machines because
you get 14 you probably take that it's a
um it's a decision based on the
probability of how much I can make and
if you can make more with um with
another machine I'm sure the other
machine will wipe out the obsolete the
one you can't make enough money on but
again the the putting a
favoring the uh
taking recognize that we have two sets
of operations here in the state we have
what some can say is the smaller
Charities the Lucky Seven Bingo and vfws
with the Lucky Sevens and the mega
operations which are the HHR casinos
this bill will at least give them a
little bit of parity with a 10 with the
ability to create a ten dollar ticket
which is an electronic ticket which the
lottery knows each and every nickel that
goes into the uh into the pot what comes
out it's easy off that's why the bill
was written to make it electronic only
so that the audit Trail is clean and as
representative Albany said uh with
mixing several deals together you won't
be able to absolutely identify gee the
big number is gone so you can keep
playing because it's not so obvious when
Joe says I got the 500 winner and
everyone goes up put the Box away I
don't buy any more of those the
electronic it's um there's more than one
terminal there's not people you know
they're playing it in the uh multiple
deals in the same computer uh makes more
prizes available and people don't
yep representative fellows
um I'm having a hard time with the
terminology in the bill so what I see
here is I have you have
um Lucky Seven ticket
pack
or a ticket card
or you also have a dispenser which I was
assuming
dispensed a card and you're talking
about electronic machine which doesn't
dispense anything it just shows it on
the screen so I'm getting really
confused and my other question is why do
why would anybody want 50 Cent ones well
welcome to the world of Lucky Sevens the
in the last 10 years we've had an
evolution from the paper ticket to a old
paramutual commission that said you
could have a ticket that could be
produced in a dispenser originally we
had dispensers with a pile of four or
five and chickens you'd pull them out
then the computer people of the world
said you know we can produce a pull tab
which emulates the action the exactly of
a piece of paper and so we have now we
have both paper tickets and computer
generator tickets so you see some terms
in this bill that are words of art a
ticket is both a piece of paper today at
a computer program
a deal can be a pile of tickets in a box
or a entry into the central processing
unit of the dispenser so you have a
physical ticket and you have an
electronic ticket and they're both uh in
the same under the same licensing and
the same uh Paradigm in that they have a
certain amount of winning tickets in a
deal and the cost of the deal is less
than you have a net guaranteed return so
if you pay a thousand dollars for the
Box you give a 200 price you net 800 but
there's two forms of the exact same
thing there's the electronic form and
the paper form the
perception of the older people playing
bingo love 50 Cent tickets for five
dollars you get 25 tickets
so that that bottom line here Mary uh I
forget Mary's and she passed away
Mary Griffin who was a senior in Derry
and a big supporter of senior
opportunities for gambling wanted to
keep that 50 Cent ticket so uh you know
a box of 50 Cent tickets people can play
for two or three dollars and have more
tickets more opportunity so as the
market matured people said I don't want
to buy a 50 Cent ticket give me a dollar
ticket give me a two dollar ticket uh
same process just a bigger
pay in bigger payout so there's exact
they're exactly the same but one exists
as many things exist today inside the
computer and the other exists in the
they're the same but if you look at
those words they're just words of art
the ticket is electronic or paper and
the dispenses either the computer or the
person handing it out
representative Susan Owen thank you
there is one other difference between
the paper and the Machine and as I said
the machine is pretty
slow
compared to the HRM which is slow can a
bit compared with the slot machine on
but
the the difference between them
generally in gambling isn't it that on a
person can who is addicted can spend all
of their time sitting in front of the
machine pushing the button
hoping to win enough to make up for what
they've lost
and um
doesn't that make a difference in when
you're talking about a social game like
bingo
or the people who show up at three
o'clock in the afternoon to have some
coffee and chat with their neighbors and
friends that they only see at that bingo
hall on if they're instead playing the
machine is there a question related to
that yeah I did put some questions okay
your points are always valid relative to
the person who can't control their
gambling instincts and a certain type of
device might uh augment their bad habit
but there's I'm sitting in front of the
ways of means commission and looking in
the history of the last 10 years we've
decided that there's something that
outweighs that protection of the person
I see some lit up
things over there any else want to ask a
question thank you very much for
entertaining all of our questions thank
you very much that chair recognizes Fran
good morning for the record my name is
Fran Wendell though I represent
Powerhouse gaming and I must apologize
to the committee my orange badge decided
to go on vacation and is hiding
somewhere in a pocket so I am a
registered lobbyist and I'm speaking on
behalf of my client
um we support the ten dollar
that we are open to something lesser as
we talked
we became concerned about
proliferation
of the
new new places
and I I know some of you who have
followed this for many years can't
believe that you're hearing me say
perhaps ten dollars is a little bit too
quick uh too aggressive
um
if the committee wanted to consider a
phase-in you know to two dollars or
three dollars and then after two years
if no problems have come up that it
could increase to the next level uh that
might be a little more convoluted than
you care to do
um just as a matter of point the thing
that I like about the electronic means
of Lucky Sevens is as I've grown older
my vision is not what it used to be and
to open this little peel thing and you
have to get a magnifying glass out to
read it is problematic for the elderly
and also I have gotten arthritis
somewhat in my fingers and peeling those
tabs is not the easiest so I can see
whether I won or lost right there on a
well-lit big screen and it makes it much
easier
um
as the prior speaker mentioned the
electronic form is much easier for
lottery to audit everything is right
there in black and white whether the
person chooses to ask for a copy of the
winnings from the machine or just to go
with the readout
um
the reason the primary reason to
increase it was to give them a little
bit of parity when you have these
facilities that
have vets that are now 25 when you look
at the old scratch tickets when they
started out they were very small and now
you routinely see winners that bought a
10 ticket or twenty five dollar ticket a
one chance you know type thing with the
scratch tickets so it's not out of the
realm to make these facilities
more competitive I wish there were a
little bit more talking about the good
that these Charities and service
organizations do with the money that
they are getting if you were to look at
long term statistics from Lottery you
will see that Bingo sales were going
down down down down Lucky Sevens were
kind of static but when Electronics came
into play it was like everybody had an
advantage everybody's numbers initially
went up Bingo has returned to the slide
could be because there's so fewer
facilities because it's just not worth
it for the time involved for the
Charities to be able to cover those
hours
so um
my client would be fine for something
less than ten dollars
um we'll leave that up to you two
dollars is a very easy change or three
dollars but we will support whatever the
committee decides
we just don't know if there are
unintended consequences with all of a
sudden going boom and we want to prevent
that believe me I my client most of
their facilities are the smaller more
North Country facilities who probably
will not change from a dollar they'll
leave their machines at a dollar or they
might try two dollars
um I would think that the only ones who
really would want this would be large
Halls
that are close to the casinos along the
borderline of the state to keep those
people here instead of taking their
dollars to Massachusetts
um I'd be more than happy to answer into
speaker said there's nothing else to be
said we have asked a lot of questions
but we have a lot of new people in this
committee so representative fellows has
a question if you'd be open to this like
Groundhog Day
for you maybe representative fellows so
I'm I'm from I'm from um Plymouth
holderness in Hebron District so I'm
glad to hear somebody who recognizes
that there are things going on north of
Concord and um can you tell me again who
your client is and where you have
facilities in the North Country
uh did bring the list with me up the
Plymouth VFW I believe is one
um
the
North Country is could be seasonal as
well for the most part of the year they
might
stay at one dollar or go up to two
dollars but when you have Prime ski
season or summer season they might say
okay for the months of such and such to
such and such we'll try the higher
ticket when we have a lot of people from
out of state that are used to having
representative Platt thank you I've
heard support for two dollars I've heard
support for ten dollars you're flexible
could go anywhere in that range have you
placed odds in what ways and means we'll
do
pardon me
it was a joke uh have you placed odds on
what ways and means we'll come out with
I suspect you'll
take a bowl and put some numbers in it
we don't want to trigger a long time
study by starting with something lesser
having in the back of our mind well if
this goes fine
maybe we'll come back and say now can we
go to five and bear in mind it does not
mandate it says shall not exceed 10.
so a lot of them may not change from the
dollar but it gives the enabling
legislation the opportunity for those
who feel that it would help their
viability that they could do so and
nothing says once you do it you have to
stay there if you buy a deal and it just
doesn't work then you sell out that deal
and you go and representative Olney was
perfectly right when it used to be one
deal three thousand five hundred tickets
and it was a a busy night you got
somebody sitting at the end of the bar
watching because a lot of times it's the
bartender who ends up selling the
tickets they're counting and they say
the 500 hasn't been hit but when we were
able to commingly it started out being
called co-mingling before they
officially increased the deal to up to
fourteen thousand it's harder to keep
track of
particularly when you've got a machine
there and a machine there and a machine
there it's really hard to follow who's
winning and what they won and how many
more would be left because with multiple
deals you don't have just one 500 prize
you might have
six
so it adds a little bit of a safety
check there as well
thank you very much thank you okay the
chair will recognize Ashley
I'm not going to be able to pronounce
your last name from Grover gaming please
come up and introduce yourself and I
know you but I don't know how to
pronounce your last name
it's okay nobody does
my name is Ashley chairmanus and I do
represent grower gaming here in the
state I wanted to speak to the committee
and thank you very much for hearing me
on behalf of the two dollar ticket we do
support a two dollar ticket because
let's keep in mind that the majority of
our customers right now our Partnerships
are the posts and The Lodges of of the
world the vfws the American Legions the
Moose lodges the Elks clubs
these are locations where if they were
to offer a ten dollar ticket you are
looking at a total payout of
approximately a hundred and twenty six
thousand dollars if a top prize now keep
in mind there's a prize pool that would
total that if a top prize is ten
thousand dollars your average VFW Post
or Elks Lodge is not going to have that
kind of cash on hand
um let's also keep in mind that we are
speaking about casinos and we are
speaking about bingo halls but our
actual customer is the charity that is
involved with those organizations so
while we partner with bingo halls while
we partner with casinos
we in fact have an agreement with the
charity it is the charity that
um does the payouts it is the the
charity that is is paying these players
so although we would love to down the
line see a ten dollar ticket be
available on an electronic Lucky 7
machine I think a two dollar ticket
would be an excellent way to
um ease our customers into that kind of
a world where those payouts would
actually be
possible for them
I do know that there are a majority of
our customers we do have 19 total
locations that we serve right now in the
state and I would say that the majority
of them would absolutely take on a two
dollar ticket they would not take on a
10.
thank you did you have anything else to
add I do not would you be open to
questions absolutely excellent
representative Jordan ulery
thank you for taking my question
how did it turned out if there's so many
people concerned about the 10 figure how
did it pass the Senate
um I think
and this is just speaking my own
thoughts
um I think we want to everybody wants to
see these fraternal organizations the
veteran organizations that the
charitable organizations in New
Hampshire they want to see them profit
so that they can do great things in the
community being able to increase a
the electronic wager is a great way to
do that I think
having it up to ten dollars is a great
way to kind of present that position but
after speaking with
um
our team we did decide that two dollars
is kind of a more realistic offering for
these organizations so yes initially it
was ten dollars but after going back and
um kind of thinking about it a little
more deeply and talking to some of our
locations as well we decided that the
offering a lower wager amount such as
two dollars would be a more viable offer
for
your veteran organizations or fraternals
through non-profits of the world
thank you welcome representative fellows
I apologize I missed you okay go ahead
thank you um can you just tell me what
your thoughts are on the 50 Cent ticket
do you think it's good to keep that or
you don't need it or does it really
what would be the impact of getting rid
of it I guess
um I would absolutely not suggest
getting rid of the 50 Cent ticket
New Hampshire has been used to a 50 Cent
ticket whether it was a paper pull tab
or an electronic
um Lucky Seven for as long as I am
familiar with and I haven't been in this
industry for as long as some people have
been um
members of some of these organizations
so the the idea of of removing a 50 Cent
ticket I think would be detrimental to a
lot of these organizations
representative lburger
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm having a hard
time understanding
why putting an upper limit on a ticket
that doesn't say You must charge this
but you may charge this would be an
issue for an organization that could
simply say we don't want to charge 10 we
want to charge two I'd like to hear your
comments
um so thank you very much for the
question again I can only speak to my
thoughts on that
um
but there is a lot of work that goes on
behind the scenes as far as creating
these particular deals that involve
different Ouija amounts different wager
sizes so for a company to
um
support a two or five or ten dollar
wager and then have to come up with
payout scenarios for all of those and
then offer them to organizations that
most likely will not offer a ten dollar
wager
um in in my eyes that's that those are
not scenarios that would be beneficial
so it'd be very expensive and time
consuming for you to program every
different scenario yes thank you
representative Elber did you have a
follow-up yes I do thank you um
you could though say that if you know
that this group of your customers and
maybe it's your entire group of
customers doesn't want more than a two
dollar ticket that could be all you
offer
correct
okay great thank you so much thank you
okay so this is we're on Senate Bill 139
still I have don't have any more pink
cards is there anyone else here would
okay that's why I'm just re-clarifying
where we're at because we went a little
over there okay so no other pin cards no
other questions we will now close the
public healing on Senate Bill 139. okay
now we will open the public hearing on
Senate bill 192.
relative to the hours that Lucky 7
tickets may be sold and and for the
record I am involved in Lucky 7 tickets
uh and we recognize Senator Susie
welcome
thank you very much Madam chair members
of the committee for the record I'm
Donna soucy I represent Senate District
18 comprised of five Wards in the city
of Manchester and the town of Litchfield
and I am here today it appears between
you and lunch so I will be brief in the
explanation it is a very short bill
this bill would allow for Lucky sick
Lucky Seven tickets at bingo
to be sold starting at 8 A.M instead of
the current law which is 12 p.m the
amendment that the Senate made was to
make this effective upon passage I
believe there are some folks who will
testify after me that can speak more
vividly to the impact of this but
essentially there are other
gaming entities that are now selling the
Lucky 7 tickets earlier and this is to
create parity within the statute this
statute applies to those doing bingo
games and as all of you know based on
the discussions here uh there are many
forms of charitable gaming that we now
allow in the state this would allow for
the sale of those tickets at the same
time that other entities currently
charge them I actually think it may have
been an Omission when we change the
statute but nonetheless I know there are
some entities in Manchester in
particular that would be impacted by
this and that supported the legislation
so with that I would ask for your
support and happy to take any questions
thank you so much questions from the
community representative Susan Almy I
hate delaying lunch but on Valerie King
according to the Senate minutes on
testified that
the time was it was never allowed at 8
A.M
and there were two people that talked
about how they
they've lost an hour from their Lucky
Seven sales because of what the change
that was made earlier and one that opens
at 9 30 A.M
so 8 A.M seems awfully early
is that I'm not sure whether they
misquoted miss King
on that
well the reason that you will hear is
that some of the entities open early and
have coffee or refreshment people get
their bingo to in anticipation of the
game
this does not require anyone to open at
8 A.M it only says that those and I
believe at least one of the entities
because that was the request when I put
in the legislation does open that early
and would like the ability to sell at
thank you other questions from the
committee
representative fellows
is there any kind of restriction on the
Bingo part of it the hours of for Bingo
um
we I
had the statute open
um
I would need to defer to the department
because I don't see it in the chapter
before me but this is within the time
period that some of the Bingos do
currently open and they want the ability
to sell the Lucky Sevens during that
time so I can't tell you the Restriction
um representative fellows but perhaps
thank you so much thank you okay the
chair recognizes
um
Mike McLaughlin again from Community
good morning again
Madam chair members the committee Mike
McLaughlin from Community Bingo Center
the issue with this bill of reason was
put in was the Community Bingo Center on
Saturday and Sunday was running double
sessions so the initial charity would
come in in the morning and sell their
tickets and I think you've heard earlier
today what the basic operation of a
bingo event is people Gather in the
runners go around the hall selling the
tickets the tickets are mostly sold
before the bingo starts so they a couple
hours before bingo starts to passing out
the tickets people paying for them
they're looking for the winners when the
bingo game starts everyone sits down and
plays the bingo game because the Bingo
bars come up and the balls are up and
you get up Dobby or Bingo paper so the
operation of a typical bingo game has
two stages the sale of Lucky Seven
tickets then the bingo game itself so
the bingo games usually will have five
to seven games per night of Bingo but
the Lucky Sevens or sold before the
bingo game starts so what had happened
was there were a couple of charities in
Manchester who had the early really a
session on Saturday and Sunday and
suddenly they ran a foul of the existing
law because they were selling Lucky
Seven tickets before I think it was 11
A.M so what we did with this building we
asked in the Susie was to move it back a
certain amount of time and by the time
we went through in the Senate they set
it to 8 A.M because that is the same
time that the casino and operations may
open they can run from 8 A.M to 4 00 a.m
the next day now the Bingo can run from
8 A.M to 1 a.m of the next day so it's
not a uh this is not a sea change of any
stretch this puts the starting time for
gambling or charitable gaming events at
the same time in both ends of the Bingo
Paradigm and the casino game Paradigm
but what it does do for instance the
Charities who may teslaire behind me
will say we need a couple hours before
we start the noontime game so 8 A.M
they're not going to start at 8 A.M
unless they're going to have a 10
o'clock game but the uh it gives them
the flexibility and it makes every
gambling event charitable game event the
same opportunity to open at the same
time and helps them avoid getting in
trouble with the lottery that's the main
representative Susan almie
thank you on I remember us being told at
various times that there were people who
were
um
using the Bingo machines the the Lucky
Seven machines on during maybe nine ten
hours of the day when there was a one
hour bingo game that day
is that well I think what you're talking
about is the last uh we had a issue over
the last five years of uh casinos that
had Lucky Seven machines that were
required to play Bingo
so those bingo games were opened at a
certain time during the day which would
then allow them to sell Lucky Seven
tickets in his wisdom the legislature
decided you don't even need the bingo
game anymore so that question becomes
somewhat moot in that they don't even
have a bingo requirement in a licensed
games of chance facility
but what we're talking about today is
the bingo game has to be played we're
playing seven eight games a night and
thank you very much you're welcome okay
chair recognizes
Diane Lucas from the American Legion
jutress Post 43. I hope I didn't kill
good morning members
um just for the record it's pronounced
Diana Lush
I know it doesn't look good it happens
is this better much better again thank
you very much Diana Lush for the
American Legion judges post 43.
um just for clarification
we were licensed fully licensed by The
Lottery Commission starting in September
of 2016.
with full compliance of opening our
doors at 9 30 in the morning and selling
pull tab tickets it was allowed
audited several times we were never not
arbitrarily when I was going over some
recommendations from lottery for some
rule changes to Lucky Sevens in the fall
of 22
I discovered
the new language saying that pull tabs
cannot be sold prior to noon time when
in conjunction with a bingo event so I
contacted lottery I said but we've been
licensed since 2016 and selling tickets
so it kind of caused a little bit of a
stir ultimately it was discovered that a
bill was presented in 2018
well past the two years I was licensed
and currently licensed it got changed
to Newt
this little history as to how why I
think there was it was a mistake is what
I've been told so we're just here to
right the wrong this has severely
impacted my Saturday morning Bingo for
the American veterans of the Judas post
we still open at 9 30. people still are
there waiting at the door because it is
a social event as you've heard but we
cannot sell those tickets until noon but
our Bingo is done and over with pretty
much by two o'clock
ticket sales we don't sell past a
certain time because we need to balance
the funds I have several Financial
reports to complete for the Lottery
Commission and obviously I need to
balance that so we've been stricken down
to about an hour to an hour and 15
minutes of sale time for our pull tabs
which is really the backbone of our
Revenue
Saturday mornings we have lost since
October because we had to stop because
this was the law on the books now
and those about six months roughly 2500
to 3 000 every Saturday
so and that's affecting our veterans
directly
um
Mike was correct
we do sell the majority of our pull tab
tickets Our Lucky Seven tickets prior to
the start of our game our game starts at
11 30 A.M
so people can dab it's it's obviously
very hard to open pull tab tickets
manually and dub at the same time so
this is why the people do like to
purchase their tickets in advance of the
Bingo starting we do still sell while
the games are being
conducted and then at our intermission
about halfway through and then that's
pretty much where they stop so our our
Revenue stream like I said has been
severely affected and nobody can explain
why the bill was passed in 2018
especially to affect a licensed charity
thank you for very much for your
testimony and for all that you do thank
you
okay the chair will recognize
this is Stacy Bergeron from boxes of
my height and microphones are always an
issue for me so thank you for bearing
with me I am the executive director and
founder of an organization called boxes
of love for the homeless which started
out much like we said boxes of love for
the homeless and we've expanded over the
five years to serve our seniors living
in poverty through subsidized housing we
throw days of caring for our rural
homeless who don't have access to
Services because they're not centrally
located in a large city or metropolitan
area and we also do inner city Outreach
as well as supporting through our Joshua
Project other Charities that are helping
people close the gap between
homelessness and housing so we do quite
a bit we're very small charity we have
two employees and we currently have one
Bingo day which is Sunday and since you
mentioned it it is a very much a senior
day we love our Sundays and all of our
seniors but for us just like with
teacher's post there's been a
significant impact to our Revenue as a
result of the reduction in ticket sale
hours so we open the hall or our game
start at 11 and we were allowed to sell
Lucky Sevens up until our game started
at one now we can only sell them for an
hour which has had a huge impact on the
number of deals we're able to do and if
if I might just add one other thing if
that's okay with the committee we talked
about you know all these Charities who
are sort of waiting to get in I think
it's important to understand how
complicated the process is and how much
is required of an executive director and
the and their team in order to run a
bingo so you know a lot of small
Charities are shy away from it because
it's you know the licensing is the
responsibility of the charity
understanding the financials or the
responsibility of the charity making
sure everything is you know we're a lily
bite organization we don't have any big
salaries and so it's it's really
important to understand that this
doesn't necessarily attract the little
guys I think we're talking about
big big rooms so thank you any questions
for me
any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you so much for coming
and for everything you do thank you okay
I do not have any more pink cards for
Senate Bill 192. yes would you like to
please give us your official title I'm
not sure and I don't want to mess it up
thank you hi good morning my name is
Valerie King I work for New Hampshire
lottery I oversee the division that
oversees charitable gaming I believe our
current name is enforcement and
compliance I just wanted to
clarify some information that was
provided and then offer to answer any
questions that you may have
um
so the hours were set in rules at least
as far back as 2015 I believe
so and at that time it was always the
the times that um
the the noon time hours for when it's in
conjunction with bingo so that has been
in place since at least 2015 they put it
into the statute I believe in 2018 but
it has been there for a significant
amount of time
um I just wanted to clarify that because
there was some indication that it was
allowed at one time to go as early as
eight but as far as I can tell from our
records that's not true at least from
is it Deputy Commissioner I'm not sure
your title I'm a division director
division director any questions for the
division director yes representative
Platt
have you are you a pining on the bill
one way or the other no okay I just
wanted to clarify some information that
was provided
thank you so much I think it would be
appropriate to still have you fill out a
pink card if you wouldn't mind okay
great okay guys that's all I have for
Senate bill 192. so with that we'll
close the public hearing and take a
break until one o'clock we will
reconvene and we have two more Bill
hmm
ings
sentence
hey the time being 105 five
and first up we have Senator Tim Lang
thank you community members thank you
for having me back as I introduce Senate
Bill 17 again I'm Senator Tim Lang uh
representing District 2 which is General
the Lakes Region area this proposal in
front of you would allow that any
donations received by fish and game
department for the non-game species fund
as established in RSA 212-b colon six to
be exempt from requiring approval of the
Fish and Game Commission and the
governor and executive Council
in the same manner that any funds the
department receives from non-profit
organizations are exempt from such
approval under RSA 206 colon 33-c
currently any monies that are received
from the fund are deposit into an
account that is overseen by the state
treasurer and then transferred to fish
and game department undergovers and
authority and to Governor's Authority
for the express purpose of managing
non-game species programs
the existing requirement for GNC
approval in order to even accept such
donations adds another administrative
layer that slows down the process to
getting the funding where it is needed
in a timely manner the intent of this
proposal is to streamline and simplify
the process for accepting donations to
the program fishing game is here today
and they can speak to the details and
the specifics and this bill was put in
at their requests so I'm happy to take
thank you representative plett thank you
for taking my question Senator why do we
have to have approval for game fishing
funding
but what if we had game funding again
I'll let fishing game answer that that
we currently have a statute that creates
that non-species game fund and so it's
allowed anybody any citizen who makes a
donation into that fund we'd be able to
bypass some of the red tape and get the
money into the fund so the department
can expend it to the for the purposes
yes representative Army
thank you
uh by Disclosure I give to this fund and
I think it's been 14 years I think they
told me last time
um and I am kind of appalled that it
goes through governor and Council I had
no idea
a lot of people don't and again it's
just it's an administrative red tape I
think we can do away with here at the
oh representative orrs thank you Mr
chair Tim thanks for taking my question
Senator Lang
the do you know why it was set up
originally why it was structured that
way any idea
I do not I was in the legislature back
then so I don't know I know originally
most the standing practice has been for
donations generally go through the
executive Council but in a specific
instance there are other exemptions and
I I understand in law this would just be
adding to that exemption to bypass that
red tape because it has a designated
purpose it's not a general fund kind of
donation okay yeah I'm surprised there
isn't like a fund for whatever the Loon
fund or maybe representative Omni knows
but I'm just surprised a donation that's
going to help Wildlife has to go through
fish and game and there's not a separate
a loon fund or whatever the money's for
I'd be interested to know if ret bomb he
wants to share what that was for so
thank you very much sure
representative almi I'd be willing to
share it if I'm allowed to but this is a
that's a good point it's a great
question from fish and game was coming
up next
all right yes we can we can discuss that
later anything else any other questions
next up we have Mike marshan from Fish
okay you may proceed introduce yourself
and uh good afternoon uh thank you
members of the committee uh my name is
Mike marshand I'm the supervisor of the
non-game and endangered Wildlife program
I'm here in support of Senate Bill 17.
uh
representing the fish and game
department and the Fish and Game
Commission
um so I'd like to take a few minutes
just to talk about the non-game program
and thank you for Senator Lang for
introducing this
um the legislature uh set up the
non-game program in 1988 so we're happy
to be celebrating our 35th Anniversary
this year
um and we have a pretty wide breadth
we're actually the state uh entity
responsible for the protection of all
the species that aren't actively hunted
fished or trapped for and that's
actually 80 percent of the vertebrate
species in the state so the birds the
mammals uh the reptiles amphibians and
we're also responsible for all the
invertebrates the pollinators of our
plants uh the the muscles that keep our
lakes and rivers clean so a pretty wide
um breadth of responsibility yet our
program is pretty uniquely set up for a
state agency we actually depend on uh
donations and that's how it was set up
from the start and
um we do not receive fishing and hunting
license Revenue as the other programs in
the fish and game do so we really do
depend on those donations the donations
then go even further they help us bring
in a additional federal grants that
require non-federal match so they go
that much further we think we've been a
really successful in the 35 years that
we've had in both keeping common species
common as well as recovering threatening
and endangered species educating the
public and so on
so uh as mentioned this is a dedicated
account that has been established uh
previously and we're just looking to
streamline process and bring it in to be
consistent with some other programs and
uh where non-profit programs within the
department
um are streamlined in a similar way uh
to not require additional approvals
um I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank all of our generous donors to the
program we have over 4 500 donors a year
to the program
so very appreciative of all those in
sponsoring our state program again for
Unique within state government to be run
off of on private donations and really
really hoping to streamline the process
for accepting those donations and
maximizing where that money
um the donors money is going into the
conservation of those species and
finally I'll just mention
um
many of our donors are transitioning to
annual contributions through financial
institutions and charitable foundations
and we've had several people Express
concern about needing additional
approvals
um you know as they set those up
following their passing and and you know
wanting their money to be guaranteed to
go where
um they're setting it up so in their
will so I'd be happy to take any
questions we're excited about the
opportunity I appreciate the time to
speak to this bill today
uh that's
right oh
thank you for mentioning
um
representative Platt yes thanks for
taking my question why limit this to
non-game funding why can't the fish and
game receive funding for game species
for donations
a governor approval the non-game program
is unique within the department where
we're really the primary or only program
that's
um solely you know really dependent on
those donations whereas the other game
programs have hunting and fishing
license revenues that really fund the
vast majority of that non-federal match
so they can take in donations
um but then they go through the
commission and um and if they exceed a
certain amount they go through
government Council approval
that's the way it was set up when you
know
that's the way I was set up in statute
for the legislature so if you have a
question
um any
okay any other questions representative
orrs uh thank you Mr chair I think are
you still the chair now or what anyways
my question is how much money in the not
of this non-game funds that you receive
goes to uh taking care of the wolf
um zero
so
follow-up questions
follow-up do we have a wealth population
in New Hampshire
um
I would defer to our fur Bearer
biologists to answer that but there's no
is he or she here no give it your best
shot all right
um there are no documented uh
wolf populations in New Hampshire to my
knowledge
um
there's a there's an interesting genetic
history of between wolves and coyotes
and domestic dogs that Pat Tate or fur
bear biologists would be able to provide
more information on
um
but I guess the bottom line is no we
don't have we don't there's no active
work with Wolves they're not known to
occur here so from in terms of the
non-game program
um we don't dedicate any resources to
the species
thank you you did better than the last
person from fish and game I asked that
okay any uh representative fellows
um it is my understanding correct that
this bill has nothing to do with how the
money is spent
that it's just a question of
when the money when contributions are
made to this fund which is one of the
contributions I make every year
um when that is done instead of every
month or so your agency having to go to
I don't know fiscal or geotnc whatever
instead of you having to do that
activity every month to get approval
before you can you know book those funds
as Revenue coming into you that this
bill will mean you just don't you won't
have to go through that step you'll just
collect the money and you'll just
deposit it into that fund which is used
specifically
for
non-game you know to protect the
you know the butterfly The Blue Heron
Karen butterfly and a lot some
endangered birds and that sort of thing
is that correct
uh thank you for your support and all of
what you said is correct yes none of
this is on the expenditure side we would
follow All State procedures on that we
would have to go through on the
expenditure side this is simply to
simplify the process
um and bisect that what can take several
months to go through both the Fish and
Game Commission and then the government
do we have any other questions uh yes
thank you uh
I may have other questions later on but
so when you
when something is expended
from this fund
you have
a complete control of that you don't
have to go through another process with
anybody else to to spend that money
and I have follow-up
so our budget is part of the approved
budget process that goes through the
that's approved by this to the standard
state budget so all of our
you know class lines are within their
um like any other program we have a
dedicated account
um if and then we follow State
procedures with all those so if you're
Contracting work out over a certain
amount that would go to government
Council for approval uh if you're
Contracting other workout that would go
through other Contracting processes so
essentially would follow all the um you
know the procedures that the rest of the
department would follow up
follow up so did I understand that money
in this can be used to for matching
grants and to collect other other grants
to come in
is that did I hear that or I'm making
that up yeah so the the way that the
non-game program was established was
that
um if we were successful in raising
private donations the state general fund
would contribute a matching one to one
dollar
um up to fifty thousand dollars when the
program was established and then that
was up to a hundred thousand dollars I
think in 2017.
um and then both of those sources can be
used to match uh federal funds our
primary federal funds are from the U.S
fish and wildlife service state wildlife
grants which um mirror our purpose
within the program and they require a 35
match
um
follow-up thank you follow up so
you you
alerted me that when you said the state
state general fund but you can match
federal or any other uh private uh
Foundation money and all that sort of
thing with with the money with this use
this as a match
I mean use the use this and to get a
match okay from any other source
non-profit or state or federal uh if if
public I suppose right if it's eligible
for that Source usually for us it's the
federal a Federal grant that requires a
certain matching percentage thank you
anybody have anything else
okay seeing none thank you very much
I don't have any more pink cards is
there anyone else who would like to uh
okay seeing that I'll close the hearing
what happened to The Fish and Game funds
all right and I was here when they were
I guess we have 10 minutes until
the
okay
the next hearing will start at 1 30.
good afternoon the time being 1 30 we
will now open the public hearing on
Senate Bill 191 and we will recognize
the Senator David Waters welcome home
thank you madam chair members of the
committee Senator David Waters District
4 to introduce Senate Bill 191 relative
to road toll registration surg charges
for electric uh vehicles and um what the
bill does uh and I guess I would prefer
to call it kind of the fair share bill
pay your fair share bill
um what it does in recognizing that
we're going to see potentially declining
road toll revenues because of fewer and
fewer vehicles that are going to be gas
powered that we have to find a way to
make sure that we are feeding the road
toll and that the folk folks with
electric vehicles are paying their fair
share to do to do that
um so what the bill does
is it assesses a hundred dollar
surcharge on annual registration for
electric vehicles and plug-in hybrids uh
and then this will go into the highway
fund just like it's gas tax and then
there's a provision here that 20 percent
of that may go to helping continue to
build out the EV charging system which
is something we need to do and this
would provide a revenue Source stream
for that on that particular regard I
decided not to make that mandatory or to
put in an appropriation
for the Department of Transportation to
do that because I thought that that
should be a judgment of future
legislatures or particularly of joint
fiscal that if the department wants to
come forward and say we we've got some
money we've got some projects can we use
this funding for that I I think the
legislature should get to weigh in at
that point on that so that's why the
bill is developed this way
now let me kind of talk a little bit
more about the context for
the bill
um I've mentioned the road toll issues
that are just starting to emerge now
right now we only got about one percent
or so of the vehicles in New Hampshire
are electric vehicles
um but it's increasing very rapidly
um last quarter of 2022 six percent of
all vehicles sold were electric and the
projections are for New Hampshire and I
think this is maybe a little
conservative we'll probably see sixty
thousand Vehicles by 2030 in this state
and as you know that most of the major
automobile companies have announced the
date by which they're not going to be
making uh gas powered cars anymore for
some it's 20 30 for some is 20 30 35 and
so that's the way the the manufacturers
in the in the market are are going and
it'll be about 100 new models are coming
out in the next year or so
um a lot of a lot of much more
inexpensive cars so this you know this
is changing and I think New Hampshire
needs to be ready to make sure that um
we are prepared to make sure we can
still uh fund our transportation system
now there are a lot of options well you
know everybody recognizes the issue what
are we going to do about declining gas
tax revenues in all the states been some
other approaches taken
um you may remember there's been a lot
of discussion in the house about vehicle
miles traveled over the years as a
method there is a pilot program out in
Oregon about that and um you know it
just so let me yet seemed to find the
magic of how to actually make that work
and one thing about that is if you do a
vehicle miles travel then you don't
capture anybody
um you know who's coming in from out of
state who you used to be able to get
their road toll because they're filling
up the gas station but if it's vehicle
miles traveled how do you figure out
what state they're in or
somebody commutes from Massachusetts and
spent half their amount disputes to
Massachusetts half their mileages down
there how do you apportion that out
without so interfering with people's
privacy through software to figure out
where you're driving and when so I'm not
sure that that's going to work um but
now quite a few states have gone
um towards about a dozen states that
have gone towards this model
um Wyoming goes up to 250 dollars which
is I don't know how they came up with
that but most of them are 25 to 150
um now uh this bill in our Senate weighs
and means um Senator Innis
um said look let's if we're going to do
this let's let's do it
the right way which meant calculate the
average miles traveled by a New
Hampshire motorist
um about uh 12 500 Miles figure that
they are getting 25 miles to the gallon
and then the 22 22 cents which is the
gas tax the state tax you come up with
about 105 dollars
um so 100 is a nice round figure and
it's a logic to it too this is what you
would have would be spending if you were
driving a gas car and that's what you're
contributing to the road toll so 100
kind of makes sense now when this is
done in Senate ways it means
um attention was not paid to the issue
the plug-in hybrids I think a hundred
dollars is not exactly fair for them uh
plug-in hybrid maybe about half of what
they do is going to be using gas so um I
think there's you know some suggestion
maybe we ought to maybe we want to do 50
for that and again it's fairness and I
do think that that would make uh make
some some sense so that's the that's the
math but um uh behind it and um
you know just in the other part of the
context is other efforts that are
underway to figure out how to get at
this issue and um I know the Senate has
in Senate Transportation House Bill 422
which is looking to re-establish the
committee that had been looking at what
to do about the road toll and about
electric vehicles we're likely to pass
that uh I don't think there's any
conflict between getting that committee
going again of course we have a
transportation Council which when we
folded up the commission on electric
vehicle infrastructure a few years ago
after made its report and we put some
things in legislation at that point
um you know we handed some of the duties
over electric vehicle infrastructure
over to the transportation Council and
they're doing some things too
to think that what needs to be looked at
in the future and will be Beyond this
approach is ideas about maybe putting a
surcharge on the electricity that goes
out of a charging station on the
highways and that way if they have the
appropriate metering
you could kind of figure out well how
much of that juice
ought to you to charge and you get the
out-of-staters that way most chargings
can be done at home
so uh you know you're not really going
to get homeowners to put in the
expensive meters to figure that out so
there's a lot that I think there will be
other things in the future we'll do
about that but that's why I think House
Bill 442 makes sense we'll study that
come up with some new ideas
but this we can do now it's fair it's
paying your fair share
and I'll just say another couple words
Madam chair if I may about
um the EV charging infrastructure we
have about four and a half million
dollars from the VW settlement and those
contracts are now going out they're
almost all out to help build up a fast
charge system on our interstates and our
our major non-interstate uh highways as
as well and those contracts are going
out they're going to use that that money
up I'll remind the committee that the
governor we got the Volkswagen
settlement determined as he could that
he wanted the maximum to go that could
go from that settlement into charging
infrastructure and that was that was a
smart move from the governor we also now
have 17.1 million dollars of Navy funds
from the federal government for charging
that uh we put in our application to the
feds as that came out of the
transportation bill that passed and uh
our grant proposal was accepted we're
getting a 17.1 million to continue
building out EV charging
um but you know and that's so important
for tourism you know we're kind of known
as a donor hole in New England now and
the tourists are worried about being
able to charge and then come up here
um so this is going to take care of a
lot of that but not all of it so having
a continuing
um fund so that we might be able to um
at the discretion of legislature in the
future put some more money into the
charging infrastructure
um that that's probably a good way to go
on that so I hope I've given enough of
the big picture and then the particular
details of the bill and got to take any
questions
thank you Senator that was wonderful any
questions yes representative Schamberg
thank you madam chair thank you Senator
where did you say the 17.1 million is
coming from that's in the that was in
the federal thanks for the question is
that in the Federal Transportation Bill
Federal Transit thank you very much it's
called a navi program Navi and you have
to put in a proposal to get the amount
the portion to your state there is more
money for charging infrastructure that
is going to be on a grant basis and um
you know we'll certainly be applying for
more but that's that's the way the
representative Susan Almy and then
representative fellows
thank you on
I read
maybe it was even in the Senate notes
but
um I read that there was a requirement
by the federal government that any
Chargers that come from the federal
government on cannot charge for the
electricity
how is that going to work
who's going to pay for it thanks for the
question and you know there is some
regulation around that
and um I think that that presents a kind
of a difficulty we're going to have to
work that out and that's why I think
House Bill 442
is when they that committee gets set up
again is going to have to look at that
and I think it is all the more reason
why we've got to do this we can control
this
if the feds are making some regulations
about you know their charging
infrastructure fine but this is going to
take care of our road toll and I think
what's important about the road toll
tool is that remember it's not just for
the state highways that the percentage
goes to our municipalities
so this is a way of making sure our
municipalities don't get starved for
funding for their roads and local roads
and bridges
um because the road toll Robin is going
down
foreign
fellows thank you madam chair I have two
questions one of them I I wasn't I
didn't uh get how many states are
already using this kind of fee
how many did you say yeah a dozen have
already done it thanks for your question
it doesn't have already done it okay
um there is a chart of those I could
have brought in copies but I you know
there's a there's a chart of those
um of who's done what there are several
more states that have legislation in
process this year and I don't know where
they're at but as of you know as of the
end of last year
um we had 12 and the range was 25 to 150
most of them fell in that ranged in
Wyoming's kind of an outlier at 250.
okay and my other question was
um the town clerks that collect the
registration fee are they going to be
doing this at the same time and do they
get some kind of money for doing the
processing because I didn't look at the
whole statute I just read what the bill
was yeah thanks for the question so
um what the what the um
Motor Vehicles will do either do the
software
um and they've got a little money and
get the software but it's not much
because it's pretty easy to do because
we're already at registration time
because we have the VIN number the local
clerk already knows
you know what kind of charges there are
that we already have for different kinds
of fuel types
so the local clerks will yes they'll be
collecting this
um but it will be seamless for them you
know just when they put the car in to
register it it'll pop up
on the computer that they are subject to
the hundred dollar fee and the check
then that's the cost that that's what
the person will be charged to register
their car
so I don't think it's there's no the
physical note does not indicate any
additional vocal expenditures for the
clerks
lots of hands up
um representative
yes thank you madam chair thank you
Senator
um
just a couple things that I just get a
better idea of how this is going to work
so I've got kind of two questions in one
I'm going to ask them at the same time
so uh the first thing the as you talk
about the building out the
infrastructure and using some of these
funds and some additional funds to build
out the the charging infrastructure I
guess I'm not clear on is the state
going to own these Chargers after
they're built or are we just helping
subsidize the construction of them
um and and then my second question is uh
it talks about the Department of Safety
Division of Motor Vehicles shall
determine necessary procedures for
determining Vehicles subject to the
surcharge which I think you explained
pretty black and white um it's either
plugs in or it doesn't
um I didn't know if there was anything
else in that that we we need to to we're
not saying a test request and the second
one first yeah this is pretty automatic
I think we're going to be hearing from
the folks about just how it works now
but basically the VIN number will pop up
just what you are and what you ought to
be charged because we have differential
charges for the type of fuel now right
um on registration then in terms of
ownership of of these um this is this is
generally a grant program
um and then we find a place that's what
you know if you drive up 93 and you go
to the Common Man there you I mean those
are Teslas in there but you know the
ones we're building it's usually um
somebody at a rest stop or at an exit
says we want them here
um and uh so then the grant goes to
provide cover those costs
um but the ownership I'm not exactly
sure how the ownership is at that point
I believe that the ownership is at the
the folks who are are you know putting
that that are there
um and their operation so I I think
there's a handoff there but I think I
may be corrected on that but I don't
think the state wants to be in the
business of owning zillions of charges
around here and maintaining them no
that's uh hand off
okay I think I'll just keep going around
the room if you don't mind other hands
thank you thank you
um
you set the probably a 50 roughly charge
for hybrids would be I think you use the
word more fair words more fair
um are you looking to
us to consider amending that this bill
yeah yes thank you very much I think
there's some interest in doing that on
the committee yeah I'm from
representative what yeah I have
glad to hear it
representative Susan Olney
thank you on
why not normal hybrids which I think
they're a lot more of
on it would be somewhat lower I think I
think I get about
30 to 40 percent but then I go over
mountains in the winter
and that brings it down
thanks for the question
um the calculation there is that if your
plug-in you're using juice
instead of gas and that's pretty clear
now hybrid vehicle does it runs on gas
but it has an electric battery pack but
it runs on gas
and there are some cars the darn hybrid
that get equivalent gas mileage or even
better than a hybrid
so I'm thinking we don't penalize people
for having a fuel-efficient car and if
it happened to be a hybrid or just be a
very efficient gas car I I think they're
not pulling juice
they're paying the Roto
so that's why that's why it's uh this
way
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
you mentioned that it's possible that um
especially with the FED Federal funding
that maybe some of these charges would
put in a rest area and things like that
as far as I know rest areas are owned by
the state and
um it seems like we would need to solve
the problem of who of ownership because
as you said the state and I agree with
you I don't this I don't want the state
in the business of maintaining charging
stations
so it seems like we need or would do you
agree that we might need a solution
within this bill before it can move
forward otherwise we're potentially
letting a build out happen and we don't
know who owns it and who's maintaining
it thanks for that question you know I I
think I misspoke a little I'm not
talking about just you know rest stops
on the highway you know the um on 95 and
on 93 we actually sold those areas
to the folks like Common Man and then on
95 it's other business entities so that
they could set up commercial operations
because the state can't do that
um the other places that are in the
program now that are getting the funding
is Flowing to are off the highway at an
exit and those are commercial properties
who want to host these for a variety of
a variety of reasons
um
and I think that you'll be hearing from
the people who are running those
programs that how they handle all those
issues of construction ownership and the
grant funding form
I would say in this bill representative
the court of this bill is the fair share
if you're if you have an electric
vehicle that you support
the road toll
and the highway fund
for the state roads and for admissible
roads and bridges if
there is a a desire to use some of the
funding up to 20 percent for
the
charging infrastructure we have programs
in Des and Dot which are managing how
that money would get used and dealing
with all the issues you're raising
if that happens you know what I'm saying
it's not this shall it's a May here so
um but we do have in Dot and and Des
because of these existing programs Des
runs the Volkswagen side of things
that's the way that settlement was done
dot is now
um dealing with the uh the Navy funding
so they've they've got this setup of you
know if it goes that way and a pot of
money might be coming out of the the the
the uh the dot to go into that purpose I
think they'll that that's how they deal
with those things and that's why I don't
think it was necessary to do them in
here
okay
I'm gonna take a turn
here's my question I understand the
fairness concept but is the juice worth
the squeeze this is not raising much
money in the grand scheme of things and
do you think we're kind of penalizing
people who are trying to be
environmentally friendly by then making
them pay this and we're not really
actually putting a lot of money into the
transportation fund your thoughts thanks
for the question and um it's really
two-part question it's not much now
but wait a few years
we're going to hit the point where 25 30
then 50 percent of new car sales
are going to be electric and eventually
it's going to be almost 100 percent
we're on that path
and so now cars last a long time we're
going to have a gas powered Fleet in the
state for a long time
but
the the transition is going to be
underway and every year that goes by
we're going to lose more and more
Revenue potentially out of the out of
the road toll so this is why you know if
it's 800 000 the first year
you know well that that means something
but it's going to grow
it's going to grow it's just looking at
it looks like 400 000 at the 100 Mark so
if we actually
amend it
oh this takes effect January 1 2024 so
for 2024
yeah
okay but you see the 800 000 and then
the 2400 and that's at the hundred
dollar yeah and that's that just because
um you know you got the registrations or
people's data month of birth and so you
know when it kicks in at this point
given the number of them registered now
it'll be about 800 but it's it's going
to grow fast
um and you did have a second part of
your question about fairness issue for
the people who have made a good gesture
to get an electric vehicle now and I
because I was always told that electric
vehicles were more expensive up front is
it's interesting because I you know when
um Norm major and I represent major and
I tried to do a lot of these things over
many years and a few years ago the
electric car owners came in with that
argument said wait a minute we're the
good guys right and now you're going to
penalize this and um that that's changed
now this is supported there's a record
and I think you're going to hear that
from subsequent
um subsequent testimony
um here and that people do want to pay
their fair share and let me say too
um the price point
of electric vehicles higher end models
be more expensive than gas powered or
just about crossed that threshold and
100 new vehicles coming out to go
automobile lower uh lower course and by
the way
you know today's the the 18th and the
new lists come out of which cars get the
7 500 dollar
Federal rebate
of the cost of the car
and you're telling me the feds will give
me the 700 and you can't kick a hundred
dollars into New Hampshire
well please
I'm sorry I'm getting beyond my rational
discourse on the bill but that's the way
I feel but that's good to know
representative I'm sorry I took your
turn go for it
problem thank you for taking my question
yeah the the government of this bill is
to 100 or 50 for phevs to pay fair share
in this though is some wording about
supporting a build out of infrastructure
charging infrastructure there's also
Federal money will that discourage a
private program of these charges I could
see gas station being replaced with
electric charging stations over time
thanks for the question I don't think
that we're the price point really works
yet for the private build out and that's
why there's the federal effort to get
500 000 Chargers out there
um and I I think that uh for us as a
state in terms of policy what the
governor and others have been committed
to is realizing that we've got to get a
we've got to get the basics done for the
tourism industry and for the the Auto
industry is really concerned because
they want to sell these cars and by the
way it's about the only kind of cars
they're gonna be able to sell pretty
soon
um they want to be able to tell their
customers that yeah you're going to be
able to charge if you don't have a home
charger
um so that you know I think those
factors are there will we get to the
point where the charging infrastructure
is if you know the prices come down
sufficiently that there'll be more yeah
we heard you know in the commission we
had on EV infrastructure we had the um
gas station and the uh convenience store
owners come in and they're real
interested in what this transition and
you know they kind of like charging
because
um let's say it takes 10 minutes 15
minutes for some cars to get up to the
uh 80 charge on a fast charge
um well what are they going to do
they're going to the store and buy
something right and uh so I I think
these are questions that
um will will be answered over time but
for right now
uh this is something we can do to make
sure we have the road toll and then if
it looks like it's a good investment for
us to put some of this money into the
Chargers that's something that physical
joint physical and legislature can
decide because it's just a May here
all right we'll keep going around this
corner representative Bolton
thank you madam chair thank you Senator
regarding the actual rollout of um you
know should this pass and it's going to
require the department of safety to to
develop software that the city and town
clerks will be utilizing is that I mean
have the city and town clerk Association
weighed in as far as realistically
putting this into effect in 2024
thanks that's why we have the date here
to to the first of January now well
that's what we were told that what could
work as I said it's not it's not a
complicated software fix it it just
isn't but I think there will be folks
here who can talk a bit more about that
okay thank you
other questions on this side yes
representative lippley thank you madam
chair
thank you Senator
um I guess I'm thinking about this as a
mom of a family and you know when I pay
to register my car every year it's
expensive it's like I don't know maybe
two or three hundred bucks this if you
add 100 bucks on top like
that's a huge percentage increase for
folks so I guess I'm thinking about it
as like on like the perspective of the
family budget
um and I'm thinking what are you know
when we set policy
we usually do so to affect
uh behavior that we find desirable and
it seems like this one does the opposite
so I'm concerned so I feel like we
haven't been able to pass on the house
side I don't know maybe you guys have
got stuff done on the on the other side
of the wall where we are doing anything
to promote sale of electric vehicles in
New Hampshire so we're not where our
neighbors are on this we're not
facilitating electric vehicles in any
way and here we are ready to impose
attacks on folks who like maybe went to
Massachusetts to buy an electric vehicle
because they couldn't find one on their
dealer's lot
um so it seems like we're
I don't know why we would want to
to tax folks who are making a choice
that has less of an impact
on the air and I'm thinking about on the
roads most electric vehicles I mean
maybe they're getting heavier and
heavier but if we need to increase
revenues it seems to me we could do it
based on the weight of the car
um rather than on the fuel it's
um it's consuming it doesn't feel like a
policy that is is influencing people to
make choices that benefit Society it
feels like the opposite and I hear you
saying that we're just about past this
threshold we're not right we're not
there we're not doing anything to
encourage people in New Hampshire to
move this direction so I'm wondering why
are we so why would we consider so
quickly
taxing that choice because we need
people to move that direction not slow
them down I understand we need to raise
the revenue but it seems like
um the wrong thing to be taxing and it
seems to me like if you want I
understand it's confusing to try and
figure out you know how many miles
people drive but if I don't drive a lot
and I choose to buy an electric vehicle
I'm
really
um being charged a lot for that seems
like we could we could catch this on the
how much does your vehicle weigh and we
could catch it on you know the total end
we could catch it on if people do charge
up on the road you know we could have
represented a text for that as well
maybe get to a question for the summer
yeah why I heard some questions okay
good but I I guess I'm surprised to
to see this come forward because I don't
see it as a package of oh well we're
doing this to support electric vehicles
and so then it seems fair right so I
guess I don't see it as paying your fair
share it feels unfair and like it
doesn't promote Behavior we want to see
so can you help me yeah I'll try clearly
I'm missing something so can you help me
get to where you are thank you thank you
and so I said I think you're going to
hear from um
folks who very much are advocates for
electric vehicles and have a lot to do
with the people who have made the choice
of buying one and the psychology of that
and and the costs and so on
um to answer I mean a couple questions
there I'll try to my best to answer them
um
if you have bought one of these cars
you're going to be saving
about a hundred dollars a year on gas
tax
that's you know I mean 12 000 miles a
year yes there are people who Drive West
so people drive a whole lot more but
that's the average for the for the state
and if that's 25 gallons on an average
you know fuel efficiency or 25 miles to
the gallon you do you do the math and
you
22 for the state gas tax and it's a
hundred dollars
so you're saving
um on the gas
and and you still want to be able to
drive on some roads that aren't full of
potholes right and you want to go across
bridges that are are safe because you're
driving a car
um so I I think that the fairness
argument really does does work and I
don't think it does anything to really
discourage folks as I said you're
getting a 7 or 500 rebate to buy one of
these things
um you're saving money from the get-go
you're also saving a lot of money on
repair on one of these vehicles a lot of
money because it's just very little you
replace the tires and a few other things
that are not not much else you have to
repair one of these vehicles so the cost
of ownership over the lifetime of the
car is way down as well so there's a lot
of financial
Parts on that
um
and uh you know in terms of the the
fairness I mean I will say it is Senator
Ennis so you cannot find a more
conservative person and you know there
we are in ways and means and this came
through unanimously that committee with
his amendment to do it this way and you
know she's the Senate so I mean look I
don't like charging fees either I don't
like taxes either I mean you heard it
from Democrat okay
um but I I do I I've been on
Transportation since I've been in the
Senate you know and we have to we have
we have struggled to fund our roads
and now we're facing this this
transitional time and it is coming it is
coming you know the dealers in New
Hampshire are selling these vehicles
um and it's coming it's going to be
faster and faster in terms of the weight
argument we already do have weight
differentials for classes of vehicles
but Passenger cars
um you know yes some of these vehicles
are are heavier
but with the reduction in the weight of
battery packs uh and the cost of
vehicles you know there's going to be
several Vehicles there are some now
under thirty thousand dollars there's
gonna be a whole lot of these vehicles
under thirty thousand dollars there are
Imports that are at twelve thousand
dollars for an electric vehicle five
seater with um with a with a 200 mile
range you know I mean there's gonna be a
lot of lower cost ones that they don't
wait as way as much so I'm not sure we
can catch it that way we do that with
truck sound passenger vehicles but I
don't I don't I guess I don't see an
alternative then
doing it this way and I don't I don't
think I answer your questions because I
mean I I share them you know but I think
that's the the practicality of this
policy and doing it this way I think can
be called a fairness
and I just gently would like to remind
committee members that in a public
hearing situation we're not here to
debate yeah and we're here to ask
factual questions on why they chose to
do certain things in their bills so I
thank you for accommodating us and I do
think we will have I know there are
other pink cards and there are folks who
yes and we can certainly offline have
many more conversations about this or we
can certainly schedule a work session
and maybe you could participate in that
thank you again for your accommodation
question okay we have other hands though
so let me address some other people and
then we'll come back to you
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chair without implying
that I'm endorsing this approach I'm
wondering whether you would support the
idea of abandoning the gas tax on all
cars
and amending this bill to apply a one
hundred dollar surcharge to the
registration of all vehicles regardless
of whether the what their fuel is
well thanks for your question and you
know I I think we're going to face that
kind of issue in the kind of larger
existential question about what do we do
about the gas tax at some point in time
that's a big question
uh and um part of that question is that
and why we can't really do it now is
that you know if you live over my area
and you see the the cars that go through
the toll booths and over about half of
out of state plates
they're buying gas here
if we right now got rid of the gas tax
we would not pick up any of that that
Revenue
um and so that's why I suggested with
442 there's going to be ways to think
about you know is there a transition
Point
um where the larger picture and this is
what you know representative major
thought about this in a sense you know
when he had his very exquisitely
detailed thing about differential
vehicle miles traveled and this would
get at lots of different things and
there might have been a way to capture
the out of state but
um we couldn't get there whereas this is
the kind of low-hanging fruit that we
can we can solve a problem now and I
think for really the foreseeable future
by taking this approach and then have
you know deal with the much bigger ones
you know 10 15 years from now when we
really are
kind of really getting Beyond these
vehicles and and gas powered vehicles
the kind of thing you're talking about I
mean I've thought about it you know like
well could we do a full replace at some
point and we'll probably have to but I
don't I don't see a way now for that
well thanks for the question follow-up
so if if I would stipulate with you that
uh the out of uh State driver is a
serious uh problem
um
then this approach to dealing with the
um it it's a textual question I think
that it could in time but I think these
are policy issues that are so complex
that it's going to take a lot of work
in the legislature and also look into
other states I I'm looking at other
states all the time and I as I said I
don't see anybody who's found a better
way to go at this point in time than
this this approach
all right I saw some more hands on this
side of the room representative orrs
thank you madam chair thank you Senator
so first of all I thought the hybrid
vehicles like the Prius
charge their batteries by themselves
is that true
yeah thanks a question and they're not
in this bill it's plugins and then
plug-in hybrids the Prius is not a
plug-in vehicle it's using gas to
generate the electricity in the vehicle
and they're using gas so they're not in
this bill okay so that's that shows you
how little I knew I thought all hybrids
were
gas the gas was gener powering the
batteries back up recharging the battery
tell you what and I you could come out
and see my car it's a plug-in hybrid it
gets about 40 miles 45 miles on a charge
and after that charge is done uh then
the gas engine kicks in
like a regular hybrid and get I run on
gas to charge up the battery to run the
car great yeah plug-in there's no no gas
at all it's just it's all electric okay
very good I might need a ride home so
I'm going to follow you uh if my
follow-up question follow up so I just
cons thinking about you're saying in the
next seven years by 2030 if we have 60
000 EVS on the road
has anybody been looking at the
infrastructure as in like are we gonna
go to nuclear I know Germany's firing up
their coal plants and there's nuclear
fusion you know that's an idea that's
out there so I was wondering if like you
and representative major have or
somebody already looking at that so
if and when we get there this
infrastructure is there because I'm
looking at buying one of these vehicles
so I'd like to know thanks for the
question and um you know it's a it's
actually is related to the bill and if
we're going to have charging and we're
going to have these vehicles are we
going to have the juice the electricity
form and um the utilities answer that
with yes we are electrifying
transportation we are going to be
electrifying a lot of other things in
the economy and for New England in
particular what's going to help us get
there is offshore wind
um well I'm chair of our New Hampshire
offshore wind import development is the
governor is all in and offshore wind 320
3.2 gigawatts of power the auction for
the lease areas are going to take place
very soon
and uh and that is good that's 3C Brooks
and up and down the East Coast that's
what's been developed so I I'm quite
sure we're gonna have the power supply
whether there'll be some small-scale
nuclear thrown in or in or hydrogen
generation I mean lots of things but I I
think that the planning is underway that
we know we know we've got to do this
because the fleet is going to go
electric we've got to have the charging
we've got to have the electricity
um and we're going to pay of the roads
so that's what this bill does very good
thank you
okay we'll go back around representative
liebly yes
thank you
um I just was wondering as you discuss
the bill if you discussed other
implications I'm thinking for I'm
thinking of two for example I'd like to
know if you know what kind of answers
are
you came up with when you considered
this so I'm thinking
um I think as my car gets older I pay
less
to register my car but it seems like
this would be steady would it holds hold
you know it would be a hundred dollars
which obviously the value of a hundred
dollars goes down over time but it would
still mean I have to pay quite a bit
more to register my car
um the other part of that is I'm
thinking
people in my neighborhood mostly Drive
used cars right because it's a
working-class neighborhood and I'm
thinking if you know as soon as you go
to an electric car you're gonna have to
pay a hundred bucks more every single
year to register your car it seems to me
like that is going to influence the used
car market right so if part of what we
want to do as a society is think about
the transition and getting that
transition you know at least not slowing
the transition down I'm wondering if you
discussed how
um charging a fee like that would impact
the used market and gas versus electric
vehicle used Market
well thanks for the question I'm not a
car dealer and I know there's a lot of
talk around
um you know we look at the over the last
year used car market new car market you
know pricing and so on and so forth but
I'll come back to this two things
if you at some point your used car
you're going to get another car whether
you buy a used electric car or you buy a
new electric car
you're going to be saving thousands of
dollars a year on gas
so there's that this the calculation is
here is on the 22 cents a gallon that
goes to the gas tax
gas is not 22 cents a gallon right so
the rest of the price you're paying for
a gallon you that you're saving that so
the cost the cost here and and they're
going to be more and more used cars
um but this is what the industry and
others are looking at but for us we have
to worry and it's our responsibility to
worry about how we're going to pave our
roads and how we're going to get money
to our municipalities and if the gas tax
is going to go away
what do we do well this is why I have
the bill
um the follow-up to that is just
um again I guess I'm thinking about it
from a poor folks perspective because my
neighborhood like I said is really
working class and
you know
sure there's a you know you buy a new
car there's a lot of benefits to that
that
The Upfront cost is very high so the
secondary question is this bill doesn't
push
um the 20 for investment
um in you know electric stations but I'm
also thinking in my neighborhood
um you know if you're renting an
apartment it's very unlikely that that
you're gonna have be able to plug in at
home right it's very unlikely that
you're going to be able to choose to put
solar panels on your house so I'm
wondering
um you know just thinking about folks
uh how this structure is going to happen
because if we're not we're not like
definitely investing 20 in a structure
and it sounds like we haven't really
talked about what that structure is
going to look like so as we move forward
I guess I'm just wondering if if you
know what that looks like yes
if they live in an apartment
um there are very extensive planning has
been undertaken at the governor's behest
and through the commissions that are set
up and through des and what is required
by the federal government for planning
for charging infrastructure I think we
have good plans on that yeah in terms of
the availability of charging there are
there are other bills in the legislature
that are going to try to make sure that
folks who are renters can have
opportunity to charge their uh their
cars we have Community solar
that has passed and been operation for a
while which ensures that the benefits of
low-cost solar energy are also going to
low-income folks so I I your questions
point to things that are really valid
and that's why I think the legislature
okay the support Senator probably did
not expect to take this much time
would you entertain one more question
from our ranking member I'm here and I
just think that the people who really
know what they're talking about are
behind me representative of all me did
you have a question thank you uh it's
about something that Sam Evans Brown uh
said on in the Senate hearing
on the the cost of the these Chargers
now seem to be connected to the
the uh pricing mechanism that costs more
when
when they do a large amount of charging
in a short time
and that is what all of the newer
Chargers are doing is doing a lot of
charging in a short time so that the
already high price of electricity
is a lot higher when you charge it
sounds like along the highway or
wherever you have to plug in outside of
your own house thanks for the question
um and I'll I'll do my best to provide
some answers to it and I I don't know
maybe Sam's here or not but um he was
addressing a kind of particular issue
about time of use charging and the
structure there
um when we passed some legislation a few
years ago about EV charging
infrastructure we did a lot of things in
those bills and one of it was to direct
the POC to open a docket on this time of
use issue
um so that there's a way to modulate the
impact on the grid and demand on demands
and then the use of demand charges so
that it doesn't in some ways
this rolling out and the puc is acting
on that and they have actually made some
some things on it
um
in terms of charging infrastructure you
want fast Chargers
on the highways because people want to
plug in get up to 80 percent of their
charge which might be you know getting
back up to two or 300 miles that they
can go on the charge in 10 15
20 minutes I mean that time is coming
down with new technology all the time
but that's you need fast charges on the
highway elsewhere level twos
which are just they are about you can
put in about 25 miles
in an hour
um that's what most people have at home
and uh if you have just want to get a
little a little bit of charge that's
probably likely what you know
campgrounds and folks who want to make
the big investment in an expensive
level you know the fast charge which
would cost a lot because you've got to
bring in the power supply and the
Chargers themselves are more expensive
but you can do pretty inexpensively uh
you know the charges that are Level twos
you can also just plug these things in
into a socket
and you can do that with an extension
cord
um it you only get if maybe five or six
miles
per the hour to in your charge but if
you're if the car is going to be home
for 12 or 14 hours after work until the
next morning
you know you get some charging that way
so but so representative there's a
variety of of charging infrastructure
and I think Sam was addressing the
issues around the puc and the the
charging structure for the level the
fast charge system and that is something
that needs to be addressed and I think
that and the POC is addressing it and
foreign
obviously this is a a large complex
policy issue
yeah
um
I'm recognizing from the New Hampshire
D.O.T Andre Briere I hope I got that
afternoon Madam chair members of the
committee uh Andre Brier Deputy
Commissioner nhdot
um
we uh we testify and support of this
bill for all the reasons uh given by uh
by Senator Waters
primarily uh you know we're looking at
this from both the perspective of the
long-term viability of the highway fund
uh of which we are the primary uh
uh utilizer among State agencies as well
as uh an issue of of fair contribution
to uh the infrastructure at the
construction and maintenance of which is
critical uh at an economic engine in the
state
um and as as the senator mentioned uh
the advocacy Community is also largely
in support of this bill we view this as
a as an all of the above approach this
is certainly not the only way to tackle
uh the uh the fairness issue and the
long-term uh contribution of EV uh
operators to the uh to the highway
infrastructure the state and we do think
it's very critical that we capture
out-of-state drivers who are also uh a
big user of of our state roadways there
are different ways to do that as as was
mentioned some states are experimenting
but we as an nhdot are members of of
what's called ashtoe it's it's the
National Organization uh where all state
dots are are represented in this
organization there is a critical mass of
uh of consensus that's building around
this Approach at least starting this way
um because it's easily implementable
it's a step in the right direction uh to
to ensure uh equity and fairness uh
of contribution to our roadways and uh
it it doesn't have some of the
complexity around per kilowatt hour
charges things like that that ultimately
we think you know are going to be viable
but but just aren't yet so uh that
that's the uh the bulk of of the
rationale for our support while I don't
speak for the New Hampshire
Transportation Council
um the chairman Jim jalbert has
previously uh communicated to the
legislature uh the the transportation
Council support for this bill as well
and I stand by for any questions you may
have thank you very much for your
testimony any questions from the members
yes Representatives Pillsbury thank you
madam chair do you think it's viable to
look to the the existing uh gas tax
for an analogy if we're taxing the fuel
source
right can we in some fashion and I don't
know whether we can do enough of it
tax the charging stations come up with
some kind of a formulation
that may in fact include a build out of
a public infrastructure of charging
stations and
excuse me and text that yeah and I'm
looking for comparability I'm I'm sort
of bothered by the notion that one
portion of the driving public is taxed
based on fuel consumption and the other
portion of the driving population is
taxing an entirely different parameter
uh namely a flat fee per year uh yeah I
understood thank you for the question
and I think uh the senator got to some
of that this is a this is a road toll
equivalency uh because of the
complexities right now about charging
like you said per kilowatt hour just
like we charge per gallon we would not
we as dot are in support of that long
term as well
um you know which approach combination
of approaches you take different states
are experimenting with different ways to
do it some states are doing both the
problem being and I think this is where
Sam Evans Brown's testimony is relevant
and and perhaps this committee will get
to hear some of that from from other
speakers is uh home charging so home
charging uh there's not separate
metering on that while you could do a
per kilowatt hour charge on EV charging
stations that are in public home
charging is is difficult in that regard
um so there's some Equity issues long
term there's there's a lot of
supposition that home charging may go to
separately metered charging at some
point it's just not there yet so uh I
think your question is very valid one
it's certainly one that uh all the
states are talking about we're just not
the senator mentioned a another bill
that has a study committee in it to
study this exact issue are you aware
that we'll be participating in that we
are and we're also in support of that
bill excellent thank you other questions
from the committee representative Army
thank you and I don't understand why it
takes eight months or so to set up the
new registration forms or rather
registration uh
on
data sheets that come in because you got
through uh representative Majors efforts
you've got a Federal grant that allowed
you to as I remember
attach the VN number of every car in
this state to the license plate
yes ma'am thank you for the question
that that is not DOT that would be a
department of safety questions
sadly defer to them on that but assuming
that you had that couldn't you
all you're going to do is take the
registration form and add yet another on
another item to it
right I'm sorry I can't speak to that
that is not that's not in Dot's realm um
departments they're doing they're doing
the registration yes yes so it wasn't
dot that was
yes ma'am
hanging it up I think I saw okay other
questions
seeing none thank you so much for your
testimony okay the chair will recognize
uh Gary Abbott from associated general
foreign
thank you madam chairman committee
members for the record my name is Gary
Abbott I'm the Executive Vice President
of the associated general contractors
and I'm really here today in support of
this bill
um worked a number of years of
Representative Noah major trying to come
up with a road usage fee
and if you remember there were many
calculations whether it was on the
average of 20 miles to the gallon and
then how far you went and there was all
kinds of layers to that you know we
supported Norm's proposals but we
recognized they were somewhat
complicated to implement and how to put
in and I think that's where the car
registration and type of vehicle came in
but what I wanted to bring forward to
you and I think the senator did a great
job except I've been following the just
flat fee for around the country and I
can tell you so what I did sitting there
is I decided to on my phone Google it a
little bit and I found back in 2019
there were 19 States and they knew
California in 2021 was going to adopt a
hundred dollar fee I went to another
site and they say as of July 2022 30
states have now adopted a fee so I'm
looking at New Hampshire we're behind
the ball as far as adoption of this kind
of fee as the in-between to solve the
road usage fee or the compensate for
what we're losing with the EVs and you
will see like on that first one website
was myev.com and that one took all 19
and showed you exactly how they broke
out you know 140 for this 75 for the
hybrids they broke it out so I'm sure
you guys would do it I just didn't have
time to do chat GPT yet but I'm sure
that would come up with some additional
information for me but I wanted to relay
that that trend is happening as as the
senator spoke I knew that as we went
into covid we were in the 20s or so
because we were following this along
with Noah Majors bills that other states
were taking this route which is a lot
simplified compared to the formula
method and I I represent contractors
that work on the roads and we know that
the Department of Transportation gets
less funds the more electric vehicles
they got purchased so we know the
reality and I think this is the right
first step I know you brought up some
other where you might go but I think
those are where we might go in the
future this is really the stop gap for
that as an association that represents
contrary to Bill Rhodes we're okay with
the 20 percent going to charging station
we know that infrastructure needs to be
built we even know that the latest
Federal Highway infrastructure act added
money for those kind of things so
understand there's money coming from
different places and uh you know the
Senators absolutely right there's
different strings with any of these
things
but in order for those vehicles to be
sold there needs to be the
infrastructure in place so I think as
the state develops they'll become more
and more discussion of how to use that
money so I think we're here today to in
support this
I will also say from sitting there the
hundred dollars is a reasonable number
even though in some of the calculations
that know them because I remember
looking at all the spreadsheets were
higher for straight EVS so I don't think
this is going to be a match but I think
it's the first right step that you will
see that if 30 other states have already
before this session it's going to be
even more States after this year goes by
that will have these fees so I just
wanted to bring that to your attention
we're in full support of The Proposal
that's before you and I hope this
committee uh supports this legislation
are you open to questions I am excellent
any questions from the committee
yes representative Phillips
thank you madam chair I I don't know if
you can answer this question but you
seem to have been following this issue
for quite a while
um I know that when you get your vehicle
inspected
the person who does that is going to
write down the mileage on your vehicle
do you know if that information ever
gets to the state
so that so that somehow
um when they're when they go to register
if there might be some way to know how
many miles they drove in the past year
well I I think a lot of that discussion
came with Norm Majors bills this is just
a flat fee doesn't really Encompass how
many miles you have it's just the type
of vehicle but what I'd like to do is I
know Scott Breyer from the Department of
Safety who handles that is sitting
behind me whether he wants to get up and
testify
nice way to throw
no I told him you know I would try not
to put them but he is right here so he
might be the appropriate person to ask
there's a lot of people behind you have
not filled out pin cards probably for a
reason represented a pled thank you for
taking my question even if you had a
mileage-based fee you still wouldn't be
able to take in-state versus
out-of-stage driving into a
considerations into effect so it
wouldn't be any fairer necessarily would
it
every way has issues I guess is what we
want to put on the table is that no
matter what method you pick there are
pros and cons to each method and I
absolutely agreement with you I think
people were looking for the long-term
solution uh the user fee had a balance
between if you had a car with lower
mileage the fee would be adjusted but
put all that aside that's not what's
before you today it's really a flat fee
to fill a gap and I think that's the
right Next Step as we proceed forward in
the years to come I'm sure there's going
to be a lot more discussion on ways to
make the fee appropriate
thank you very much okay the chair
recognizes Catherine corkery I think
help us out with the proper
pronunciation please we're actually very
close it's porkery if you think County
Cork and County Career
corkery thank you and it is a pleasure
to be here at ways and means thank you
so much for giving me a chance to talk
today my name is Catherine corkery I
represent New Hampshire Sierra Club our
motto is enjoy explore protect
and
um we have about 14 or 15
um I wanted to point out I did hand out
the blue handout
and
um let you know that we do oppose this
bill
this kind of bill has been introduced
across the country and we've seen it
here as as you've heard many times
before
I want to point out that
this bill targets one percent of the
vehicles and I really appreciate your
phrasing Madam chair uh what was it is
the juice worth the squeeze
um this is one percent of the vehicles
out there
and we are taxing those people with a
new tax and it's a hundred dollars every
year as representative liply uh pointed
out
um this that
really negates the benefits of an
electric vehicle
um they have and I see representative
almi and I have different views on this
um
the benefits of electric vehicles is
Public Health
the emissions are are drastically
reduced if not
eliminated
and here in New Hampshire
the transportation sector is a huge
um source of air pollution in the state
and I wanted to point out that
8 000 vehicles
um
at a hundred dollars a pop isn't going
to
build much of a road
and even with this one hundred dollar
fee this 100 tax
going to 20 will go to charging
but the rest goes into the gas tax and
you know better than I do
how much actually goes to roads you know
that is sliced and diced
and to pretend that this bill
is going to build roads
I think you're fooling this bill is
is not recognizing the fact that
the gas tax gets distributed to many
many important accounts and I I do
appreciate
what we what this bill presents and I
would suggest that instead of imposing
it on the one percent of vehicles let's
put a floor on it
let's wait until it actually represents
25 of the vehicles
I mean I feel like this bill is
a prob what what a solution in search of
a problem
and I I really
um
suggests that you
look deeply in this bill
um I I will I will say oh my gosh my mom
told me to talk about the things you
like first and I didn't do that my
apologies
um
the part that says I think it starts on
line 16. where
um the construction of the electric
vehicle service equipment
on the transportation tour corridors
utilizing plans developed by the
department in consultation with des and
the transportation Council and drive
Electric New Hampshire that's really
great I I do support that piece of the
bill I think the there is a lot of
opportunity
inciting charge charging stations
but at the risk of preventing people
and at the risk of supporting Public
Health this bill is a problem in search
of a solution right is it a solution in
search of a problem
I always get those wrong but
um with that I conclude my testimony
thank you all right I see some hands up
are you open to taking some questions
representative
uh and thank you for taking questions
um
I represent Nashua Nashua right now is
uh dealing with a request to build an
asphalt plant in the familiar City and
uh one of the things that we are looking
at is the impact of traffic on the roads
so
electric vehicles will have an impact on
the roads
and from my mind they need to have
some uh
input as in financial input into the
maintenance of those roads and bridges
and I'm not sure
how
your suggestions address that
um
waiting until we have 25 percent of
electric vehicles
what happens
until then for the 24.9 percent and when
do those vehicle owners
start
paying for the maintenance of the roads
and bridges and other pieces that they
use
I I respectfully request that the
representative
remember that they electric vehicles
play pay road tolls and they also have
registration so they do pay in part
um and also uh that
the plug-in hybrids these there is a
Prius that has a plug-in so it just
confuses everything I'm sorry
um there is a plug-in Prius but those
Vehicles those
um plug-in hybrids will contribute and I
agree the electric vehicles and I I
think the owners want to contribute
however
this contribution isn't very meaningful
and and I think
what we can do is move move forward when
it can be meaningful
and in the meantime look at the gas tax
it goes all over many many agencies get
a piece of that pie and maybe it's time
to reevaluate that and send all the
money or more of the money to Road
building
follow up okay thank you
um that may be we're not charged with
that here that's not as far as I know
within the purview of this committee uh
I want to go back though to one of your
comments about
this would be a surcharge surtax
whatever we would want to call it that
people who are using gas vehicles are
paying the tax every time they fill up
you know I'm paying that all of us here
who drive gas vehicles do so again I'm
wondering about
why are we saying that it's okay to
exempt
one group of vehicle owners from
supporting roads and bridges
when we're not doing that with others I
think actually we are the heavier
Vehicles do and fleet vehicles do get
discounts on on their on their Diesel
and and gas
uh consumption
um and and I'm sure our friend who has
been noted before uh can explain
um that in more detail uh but heavier
Vehicles do more damage on the road but
they get waivers as well so
again this is 8 000 ish vehicles I don't
it's I don't think it's time yet
um for them uh to to tax them uh a
hundred dollars a year just yet when
they make up more of a percentage of the
vehicle population I think it would be
appropriate
okay more questions representative
lippley
thank you
um I appreciate everyone who's come to
testify I'm doing my research over here
um
and and what I'm looking at I don't see
any other New England states
um do you happen to know
um if the other states in New England
are taxing
um in this manner and if so which ones
and if it's at the same rate I'm sorry I
don't have it on me right now but I can
certainly get it for you
um I don't believe they are and I do
know uh when California
instituted their tax they also had
um a floor and in in which it triggered
the tax
um that they did not charge it until
after they got a certain percentage and
that just went in I think last year the
year before
thank you
other questions over here
and over here yes representative fellows
so let's thank you
um let's suppose that 80 of the cars on
the road are electric or plug-in hybrid
what how would you suggest
getting
um taxation or whatever what means would
you suggest for getting money to support
the roads well I think
um that actually is a really good
question
um there is the electricity side of
things I'm that that uh was alluded to
earlier with that time of use
um electrification uh and that is uh has
been instituted elsewhere
um and it's definitely something that a
lot of smarter people than myself have
have looked into
um and and I think it is
it it might be the way that New
Hampshire should go looking at their
electric charging
um and and working with the utilities
maybe
um and actually have a really
interesting handout that I can share
with the committee about
using electric charging fees
as opposed to like a flat fee or or
follow-up
I I would think if you
um had to put your car charging port on
a separate account from the electricity
that just goes to your whole house just
the basic fee that goes with an account
would end up costing people a lot more
than what we're talking about here
wouldn't you think so
if you did it that way we have high you
know High electric rates yeah I'm well
aware of that
um yes uh but I think that's something
that this committee can explore if they
thank you so much thank you I do not
have any more pink cards is there anyone
else who would like to speak
come on up if you're willing to
well and of course before you leave if
you could fill out a pin card as well
that'd be helpful for our Clerk
but come up uh thank you very much for
combinating US Representative Ami did
you thank you yeah I had two questions
one of them it may be outside of your
purview
um but on the one that I'm sure is in
your purview is could you explain the
differing on on miles per gallon
on Penny pennies per gallon tax
how much brings in how much no how sorry
on between large trucks medium trucks
small trucks and Passenger cars on how
much each of them are taxed by the state
at
registration
okay I work for the division
Administration I'm the administrator of
the Royal Farm Road toll administrator
which basically I administered the motor
fuel gasoline diesel taxes and the
international fuel tax agreement program
okay I say yeah that would have that
specific I could probably
take questions and bring them back to
the department and get back to you but
uh that probably be more uh Jeff
oberdank in uh registration
okay it was different back when we did
on and if sorry go ahead you probably
can't do the other one either but I want
to put a question out there in case
there's someone else who wants to
volunteer on the percentage of the on
Highway fun that goes to something other
than building and repairing roads
all right I do know that uh
Local 6A at the State Constitution only
allows the money to go to construction
maintenance
we leave the bond pay the bonds off on
the roads there is a stipulation that it
can be used for enforcement of the
traffic that department of safety gets a
piece of it I believe there's a cap for
safety I'm not sure the exact cap I
think it's about 23 or 24 percent
and uh for the most part the big issues
are that I'm aware of the highway fund
other than safety the big issues there
is the Department of Transportation
I think they get about 70 something
percent
here they probably can answer the
question so safety takes that much
no we only take like 20 it's like 22 23
I don't have the exact amount but I know
there's a cap on it
yeah there is a cap in the statute that
how much safety can get versus uh Dot
and safety it uses it for the state
troopers
um just the State Troopers that are
assigned to uh High state roads
um if there are sites like the turnpikes
and so forth that funded out of the
turnpike fund yeah and Troopers that do
more uh investigative work of funded out
of general fund
I think it was uh Mr Abbott who told us
about the roughly 30 states that he'd
identified by a quick look on I assume
your iPhone
that have adopted some kind of flat rate
system for
getting
funds from electric vehicles that don't
otherwise pay a gas tax or a road tow
whatever you want to call it I'm
wondering whether you've done a survey
of any sort whether you have anything
that you could provide us that would
help help paint that picture for us I
don't I can I can get you that
information but I would say Gary Gary
Abbott's uh what he stated about 30
States is probably very accurate I don't
have the exact number but I'd be happy
to find that out for you but I think I
think that would be helpful yeah
if you could that'd be great and and I
think there was definitely some interest
representative Spielberg
thank you madam chair
um can I correct that error
road toll is currently 22 cents a gallon
for gasoline uh road toll is
22.2 cents per gallon for gasoline
diesel
and is there any other fuel product we
apply that text to C and G
compressed natural gas propane and uh
We There are taxes on alternative fuels
now
um the only one all of which go to the
represent rames did you have another
thank you for coming up all right uh
don't forget pink card okay I just uh a
few things is uh make sure that
department safety is completely neutral
on this bill
and um
I I do I do sit on the international
field tax agreement Board of Trustees
and I and I will tell you that um
that all the states are really looking
into these feasts and um
I'm just giving you what I hear
nationally on the national Federation of
tax administrators in international fuel
tax agreement and I think what will
happen I think it's going to be about 20
years before gasoline and Diesel I think
it's going to be a mix it's going to be
gasoline Diesel and Electric
but we're going with that is I think
what you're going to see in several
years to come is going to be basically a
mileage tax they're going to have to do
something because reason the gasoline
tax is so fair because you purchased the
gasoline that you actually use the taxes
based on usage
and that's probably the first way to do
attacks but
probably just added that but
thank you we appreciate your input
um just a quick question Who should I
send the uh want to get that information
could you send it to me and then I'll
make sure everyone on the committee gets
it I will do that thank you appreciate
that
and just just so you know guys as a
reminder that is the typical format is
if you have a question you run it
through the chair and then the
information comes to the chair and I
send it back out
just so that we don't bog our agencies
down with too many little questions
along the way okay no more pink cards so
we will now close the public hearing on
Senate bill 191.
and we are done for today and I am
planning to schedule a bunch of hearings
next Tuesday and Wednesday and we'll see
if we're ready to do some exec exact
sessions at that time as well
um obviously we got a lot of information
today I kind of need to process it a
little bit and see where we're at
questions comments
yes representative
thank you madam chair I have received
something I hope I'm not the only one
who got uh information about Senate 260
FN and I don't know whether I was
privileged to be the only one I was not
and why we got it
is that the fit is that a fiscal note
that you're talking about or a bill this
I'm wondering why we got it today is the
question
uh maybe because it just got assigned to
our committee I don't know
um
we didn't get all of the bills from
Senate all at once we got some dribbling
in after so maybe that's why I don't
know
I
so if you need copies of any of the
bills Karen should have them in her
office and uh there's a filing drawer
that has all of them so go see her if
you're not sure where that is
she
okay
five seconds